Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Welcome back, guys, to another day of more Elden Ring!
We're at, like, part seven now.
Oh my gosh, I don't even know how much I have left of Elden Ring, to be fair.
I don't even know how many... it's all blurring together right now.
I don't know how many bosses I've done.
Everything has blurred together.
We've done so many filler episodes.
There were, like, mini bosses.
There were, like, I fought... I fought... Birdie... I fought... Boki Bird... and everything.
I've lost track.
There were so many filler episodes!
Okay, but also, like, when I miss a week of, like, any game that, like, I miss a week of, or a playthrough, I also forgot all the controls.
Um, other than, like, R1 and R2, but that's all we need.
Like, to be fair, R2 is all we need in this game.
Or R1.
R1, R2 is all we need.
Um, but yeah, I'm a little tired, uh, because, um, somebody...
Somebody keeps waking me up at five in the morning!
And then, when I'm like, no!
Stop!
And then he wakes me up at six in the morning!
And he's like, is it time yet?
Is it time?
I need, oh my gosh, I need to, like...
I think it's because, like, I've been so weak.
He's like, she's weak.
I can take advantage of her.
Because I've been, usually I would try to, like, train him to, like, start eating later and later.
But the only issue is that, um, my streams start, like, if I feed him later, uh, for, like, his morning meals.
Um, the thing is, I need to, like, be able to do that also for his, like, dinner as well.
But I can't because I start my stream at five.
Um, so I have to feed him before my stream time.
Um, I need to feed him, like, around four before, before I stream.
So he won't interrupt during my actual stream time.
And because of that, um, you know, if I feed him later in the morning, then he'll want to be fed.
It'll be, it's better for him to be fed later at night.
So then, like, the, uh, the meals.
Um, so then, like, he won't, like, you know, later on, like, it, it will be a better cycle for him.
A better routine.
Versus, like, feeding him later and then feeding him early.
Um, because then he'll get hungry earlier.
So the cycle, it, it will ruin the cycle!
It will...
But he knows, he knows I'm weak right now.
And I've been tired because he keeps waking me up.
He keeps waking me up in the morning.
And then when he wakes me up in the morning, I, I don't get a lot of sleep in the morning because of it.
Um, but also because it's been so long.
I thought it's been, maybe because I've been, like, extra tired lately.
But I haven't been able to stay up past midnight in a long time.
Like, I'm like, no, I, I'm like, it's because, no, I'm not, it's not because I'm getting old.
It's not because I'm getting old, guys.
It's because somebody is ruining my schedule!
And I hate it!
I hate that I can't, can't looking and stay awake past midnight.
I always get so tired after 11, 8, 11 p.m.
I used to be able to stay up till 4 in the morning.
What happened to me?
Her youthful optimism is gone!
Um...
Anyway, okay.
Uh, enough chitchat.
Not a long, uh, life update today.
Because we did have a long...
Oh yeah, my...
Who would have thought?
My Disney stream, my Epic Mickey stream got demonetized.
Not because of anything I showed on stream!
Mind you.
It was because it had Disney songs in it.
So...
It got...
It got copyright played by Disney songs in my Disney game.
So it was definitely not streamer friendly.
Uh...
Not because of whatever...
All the shit I showed on stream.
All the fucked up stuff I showed on stream.
And the...
And the audio...
Anime Grok Girl.
No, not that.
But it was because of the music that was in...
In the game.
Uh...
So...
So that's...
So I thought that was funny.
That my...
My Epic Mickey got demonetized.
But that's alright.
Anything...
Anything for...
Like, you know...
Disney needs more money, you know?
Disney...
Disney CEO needs to give itself another bonus retirement check.
You know?
Just like...
What's his name?
The Warner Bros...
Oh my god.
The Warner Bros CEO that gives himself a fucking like...
A million dollar bonus check.
Like Christmas bonus.
Every fucking year.
That's...
And like...
His whole job is to cut...
Like...
Budget the studio.
But yet he gives himself a million dollar Christmas bonus at the end of the year.
I...
Like...
Make it make sense.
Don't...
I thought that was like...
Okay.
That's the same guy...
That like...
Um...
I know like...
The Wally Coyote movie.
That's the same guy that like...
Tried to...
Uh...
Scrap the Wally Coyote movie for like...
A better tax break for the studio and stuff.
So I was like...
Okay.
We gotta do that.
At least like...
You know...
Don't give yourself more money.
It doesn't...
It doesn't make sense.
I don't understand.
I...
Is that the purpose of being a CEO?
Is that...
Is that what it is?
Um...
So I was so...
I was so confused.
I was like...
Oh!
Maybe they need more money.
Okay.
That makes sense.
You know?
The studio's not doing so well.
They need...
You know...
They're trying to like...
Cut things...
Uh...
So that...
You know...
They can still make more money.
And then like...
Later on...
They're like...
By the way...
This...
He just gave himself a million dollar Christmas bonus.
And I'm like...
What?
What the fuck was the point of...
Trying to help the studio...
Like...
Budget themselves.
What the fuck?
You're not...
Are you not part of the budget?
Are...
Are you not part of the whole budget system that they're trying to do?
Uh...
That guy...
He needs that new...
Doki...
Want someone...
Please...
Think of the million...
Billion dollar CEO's.
Please...
It's so hard...
Being a...
Fucking...
Billion dollar CEO...
Of a billion dollar company.
It's so...
Fucking hard...
Doki...
Why won't you think about...
The...
The CEO's.
It's so hard to have so much money.
How else will he pay for all his mistresses?
Doki...
How...
I'm playing my tiny violin.
Leave the billion dollar CEO alone Doki!
What has he done to you?
Anyway...
Um...
Let's play some Elden Ring.
Think of the babes Doki!
Will someone please...
Think of the hot babes!
Uh...
And it's 15 children!
That he clearly...
Uh...
Is gonna nepo them into success!
Oh!
Won't somebody think of the nepo babies?
Please Doki!
Uh...
I...
How will those children grow up?
Stop, Toki.
Oh my god, you want them to go to public school, you monster!
What did I walk into?
Oh, just, you know.
How the world is today.
Stop, I can only love my Oshi so much.
Alright, let's go play some Elden Ring.
Uh, okay, let's see.
Elden Ring with my zero death run, guys.
You don't understand his emotional distress after having to fire 500 more low-wage employees.
Guys, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh yes, I definitely don't understand because I'm pretty sure he's not even the one doing the firing, too.
I appreciate, like, he hires someone to do...
Because, like, I know a lot of companies actually outsource their firing because they don't want to deal with, you know, being responsible to ruining someone's life.
Like, so...
But, sometimes, um, some companies actually, like, uh, outsource their firings.
Yeah, there's, like, companies that will do it for you.
So, like, they...
They take the...
They basically, uh, do all the firings for them and act as, like, the face of it.
So, like, they don't have...
They don't have to feel, like, guilt of firing people themselves.
Um, or be like, sorry, I know we just, like, celebrated your birthday and everything, but, like, we're gonna have to...
Um, and, like, you just, uh, um, got a mortgage, uh, for your new home.
Um, thinking that you're gonna work in this company for, like, maybe, like, uh, seven more years.
Uh, but we're gonna have to let you go.
What is he barking at?
Okay, he must have heard something outside.
Um, Mr. Broken Bomb, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How else will the CEOs keep their yard afloat, Doki?
How else?
Should I do...
Okay, it should be boardless window, yeah.
Okay, I need to remember how to play this game, guys.
Give me a sec.
Okay, this is where I killed that guy.
Okay, and that's where I accidentally drank the thing.
Okay.
I'm trying to remember how to play this game, guys.
Okay, run.
Okay, I- I accidentally drank again.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Okay, that's how you run.
That's fine.
Alright.
And then...
Okay, there you go.
Okay, we wanna do it.
Alright.
Alright, figured it out, guys.
Where have I been?
Visioned a friend.
Who's friend?
Where friend at?
I don't know where to go.
Why are there so many dead bodies around me?
What happened?
I haven't been here for too long.
Oh, holy grease.
Oh, nice.
Why did so many people die?
Uh, golden.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Praise the Elden Ring.
Let's see...
Dung ahead?
The hoodie?
The hoodie's a tomato.
It's me.
I'm wearing the skin suit of my skin suit.
Of my actual skin.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, death counter.
Sorry.
I knew I forgot something.
Give me a sec.
Let me grab...
The death counter real fast.
I think it's here.
Yeah, there it is.
My zero deaths.
Clearly.
Oh my god.
Alright.
I have no idea where to go.
I'm so lost.
Oh dear.
Visions of...
Praise the message and then behold something incredible.
Okay, liar.
Oh wait, there's another area here.
I didn't go this way, right?
I came from here.
Oh, there's a witch!
Hello, witch!
Good luck!
Lost?
Oh wait, no.
That's not a witch.
Oh no, I came from...
Oh my gosh, I'm so lost.
I came from here!
So that means that this is a new area that I have yet to go.
If only I had something.
Alright, here we go.
We figured it out.
It only took us a while.
Alright.
I was pissed.
I can't use it.
I thought...
Ok, to be fair it didn't look.
I thought, I thought this was...
I thought this was like...
I don't know, I thought there was a floor there.
I thought there was a floor...
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
It was the fucking depths of hell.
Alright, let's see how much I can mine the gap.
I don't know.
I thought it was a floor.
You know?
I thought it was a child... not like a... like a child bannister.
I'm gonna keep the children out.
Okay.
Uh, fell for the bit, right?
Buddy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sajun.
Thank you for the sticker.
Thank you.
Do I have enough?
Do I have any?
Oh, I don't.
Oh, I used it all up.
I was gonna say, do I have any special orbs?
Okay, well, now we know.
We can go this way.
Still no hidden path.
Okay.
How about this way?
At least I look cool.
Hidden path ahead.
Oh, nice.
Okay, he's a liar.
Okay.
Nor.
What?
That's a good thing.
Good.
Okay, my turn.
My turn.
Alright, remember to also appraise this message.
Okay.
It's time to spread the truth.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
It's the truth and nothing but the truth.
It's the truth.
Alright, down we go.
Anything here?
Oh my God, they're too good at this.
They're too fucking good at this.
What is this?
Elden Ring?
Oh, Elden Ring.
Romeo... Rapunzel, Rapunzel, let down your golden hair.
Alright, there's a dog ahead here.
Poor dog.
Poor dog at.
Oh my god, where am I anyway?
Oh, that's where the dragon is.
I came from there.
Oh, hey.
Oh, I ran past these guys.
They're playing a little song.
Oh, there's a lot of dead bodies here.
Why?
Oh my god, he's fucking floating!
We killed him!
They picked him up!
Wait, he got picked up!
Look at him!
Oh my god, he's like...
Look at the fucking slam dunk on this guy!
It's a secret.
You're gonna find out soon, Doki.
Don't worry.
It'll be your turn soon.
Right?
What?
Try that.
Oh my god, you fuckers.
You...
You fuckers.
Alright.
Where is this?
Center.
We have fun here.
We have fun here and out there.
Could this be an item?
What?
What does that mean?
The trifecta is finally complete.
What does he mean by that?
What?
I don't know.
I don't know what he wants from me.
I'll never know what picked him up.
Oh!
Now I know.
Oh my god, he's slowly walking up towards me.
What's he gonna do?
Oh wait.
That.
Boom!
That's right.
Wait.
There's no way that guy picked him up.
Look at him.
Tree.
He can't pick nobody up.
Lump sort.
Look at these guys.
They're so weak.
Sage, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whenever Doki leaves a message on the ground in the elderly, I can't help but think.
I totally swear.
I'm up to no good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
There's a lot more.
Why is there a lot more?
Oh my god.
There's so many more.
Where did they all...
Where did they all die from?
Night ahead?
Oh.
How did you die?
Wait.
Why did that thing look at me?
Oh!
Oh my god!
It's him!
Wait.
No.
Oh my god.
It's him.
Oh my god!
It's him!
The only way I killed them was through gravity.
I can't do that again!
I don't have gravity again!
It's him!
Okay.
Okay, now I know how he... how everyone died.
It's okay.
Okay, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
Guys, it's a very funny idea.
No, no, no, I got this.
I know what to do.
Now I know where all these bloodstains come from.
Now... I thought you could do the thing.
I thought you could backstab.
I was wrong.
Is he coming after me?
Okay, he doesn't know.
Okay, is he still coming after me?
Okay, he's just walking over.
So, like... Oh my god, he is.
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm just gonna run ahead.
He's walking to me menacingly.
Wait, what's all this?
What is all this?
Oh, is it like a magic thing?
What is that?
What is this?
Wait, what is this thing?
Oh!
Oh, it is a bear.
Okay.
I was like, what is this thing that's just...
Wait!
Wait a minute.
Oh my god.
Wait, where do I go?
What?
This is a dead end.
Wait, what?
What?
This is... Oh my god, no.
Oh my god, no.
He...
Fuck.
Down?
Oh, down.
Down.
Here.
Wait.
Down?
No.
Okay.
Wait.
Not there.
No.
Toki, stop!
Like, I'm looking, I'm like...
Down?
Do I do it?
Take the...
Take the jump, Toki.
Do a flip.
Down?
Where the fuck do I go?
On the spe...
What the fuck is a spear?
There's a spear?
I have no idea what you guys are talking about.
There's nothing that looks like a spear.
Anywhere on this map.
Spear, man.
Oh, that?
That thing over there?
How the fuck do I get there?
A tree branch?
There's a tree?
Oh, that?
How the fuck do I get up there?
Oh my god, he's looking at me.
You think he knows?
Oh, he doesn't.
Why the fuck am I here?
This is like a dead end.
I think I can take him.
Oh my god!
Don't worry.
Watch this.
Oh fuck.
Oh.
Wait, no, no, no, wait.
I can't take him though.
I can't take him.
I can absolutely take this guy.
Halfway.
I got halfway.
Wait, he can fly?
Nobody told me.
Oh my god.
Nobody told me he can fly.
I'm out of my groove.
I'm out of my groove now.
I'm not...
Okay.
But I was grooving though.
Oh no.
No!
That's the thing!
I'm out of my groove.
He got me out of my groove.
I swear to god, I was grooving.
I was...
I was grooving, guys.
I was doing so well.
I was doing so well, I swear to god.
I swear to god, I was doing really well earlier.
Guys, you saw it.
You all saw it.
Flawless run.
Right there.
Flawless.
I was... I was gaming.
The spear.
Oh, shit.
Goodbye.
Alright.
We got it.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah, but I'm not gonna use it.
I'll pick it up for you guys, but I'm not gonna use it.
I got all... I got the katana.
I got anime.
Got it by my side.
Oh, I... Do I jump from there?
Yeah, but this is more anime.
Alright, actually, I wanna go to the grays first before anything.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Does... Does the guy come back?
Does this guy come back?
Chat?
I need to know.
He doesn't?
Okay, do I jump here?
Wait, here?
Here?
Did I make that?
What?
Oh, my God.
Can I even get past this?
Okay, okay.
We did it.
Nothing to worry about.
I was trying to figure out how...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Everything is okay.
And here.
Now, where do I go?
Wait, where the fuck am I?
I don't know.
I'll go down.
Where is this place?
Oh, my God.
Please.
They all came down for me.
Oh, my God.
Why did they all come down for me?
Where am I?
Okay.
Oh, they're all here.
They're all here.
They're all...
Oh, my God.
I came to the wrong area.
This is the wrong place to be.
Get me... Oh my god.
Get me out of... Oh my god.
Can I... Oh my god.
They're all here.
They're all here for me.
This has to be a grace.
Oh, there's this.
This is my grace.
I came to the wrong neighborhood.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Alright.
Okay, so where do I go now?
I don't know where to go.
I'm so lost.
Go back to my other grace.
What was it?
Was it here?
The sanctuary?
Is this the... Okay, yeah.
This is the giant room.
Alright.
Now where do I go, guys?
Up the tree branch.
Oh, this tree branch.
I see a tree branch here.
Oh!
More trees.
Alright, here.
I'll go.
Then I'm up here.
Then I go this way.
So many dead people.
Why did they all die?
Who's that lady over here?
Friendly?
Not friendly.
Not...
Okay.
I know he's not friendly now.
Okay, I need to...
Oh my god.
Okay, he cancelled my heals.
Holy shit.
Okay, we're fine.
Oh, we're not fine.
We're not fine.
I cannot be greedy.
It's fine.
I got my one heal off.
Alright.
I don't know.
Sometimes I...
I thought, you know...
Sometimes they want to be my friend.
You know?
Didn't expect a percentage.
Sorry.
Oh, maybe.
Maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe.
I got an idea.
Okay.
Remember to praise...
This message.
Next to the fucking blood state.
And they'll be like...
Wait, if that's a friend...
How did they die here?
How...
Wait a minute.
How did...
There's so many bloodstains here.
That guy ahead of us is friend.
Oh, that's weird.
How did so many people die here?
Yeah.
This friend will help us with the next boss.
Alright.
What do we get to next, guys?
Vigor.
Endurance.
Dexterity.
Arcane.
Which one?
Oh, it's a PvP spot?
Thank god.
We don't...
We never did any PvP.
Still have arcane.
So I do arcane.
Alright.
Okay.
Blessings.
We got the blessings.
Alright.
Let's go.
What the fuck?
Already another boss fight?
I literally just got here.
How do I get another boss fight?
Check the spear?
But I like my...
I like my katanas.
Where is this...
spear anyway?
To this one?
Oh, I can't even wield it.
I don't...
I'm not strong enough.
I'm too fucking weak.
Bro, I can't even hold a torch.
That's how weak I am.
I...
I can't even hold...
Oh, I can too...
I was like...
My weak noodle arms.
Alright.
I'll look at it.
Wait.
Unable with present...
Bro, I can't even hold it.
I'm too weak.
Let's see.
Boom.
My noodle arms...
Can't even hold this spear properly.
Alright.
Let's scroll...
Why do I...
Remove the area.
Alright.
Here we go.
We're gonna die.
Most likely.
Oh, hey.
Who is she?
What's this?
Wait.
Sorry.
I got text.
I got spam text.
It's like...
Regarding your...
Outstanding balance...
A resolution is available.
What the fuck is this?
It's like...
I owed money.
I'm like...
What?
My
maiden!
Alright.
Come with me.
Come with me, my maiden.
We will be the husband and wife duo.
Together.
Come over here.
There you go.
We shall be a husband and wife duo.
It will be beautiful.
Let's go.
A story for the ages.
No, no, no.
She is my current wife.
We're gonna have lots of beautiful kids together.
The power duo.
We are the power couple.
Romeo and Juliet.
And they lived happily ever after.
I never saw the...
I assume they do.
Who is he?
Oh, wait.
That's the guy that like...
Like, did the magic trick on the person.
I know Melania.
General Bredan.
I killed him.
Praetor Reichard.
Luna Princess Rani.
Willful traitors.
What?
Thy kind are all of a piece.
What makes you better than them, huh?
Look at you.
You fell off, bro.
Pillagers.
Emboldened by the flame of ambition.
His voice is hot as fuck.
Heard rid of all my neither grave.
You deserve better.
Felled by King Morgoth.
Last of all.
Oh my god.
He's like two sizes.
Of me.
All right.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Where's my wife?
Holy shit.
Oh my.
I'm so confused.
Oh.
Where's my wife?
Melania.
Please.
I do shit.
Holy shit.
It's fine.
Jellyfish time.
My real wife.
I'm like.
Oh my god.
I'm panic rolling.
I don't know his patterns.
Okay.
I'm just.
Just take everything I guess.
I guess that's my strat.
Holy shit.
Oh.
I thought he was aiming for her.
Nice.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Confuse.
That is not right.
Okay.
That's okay.
All right.
That's fine.
At least he's poisoned.
I don't want to be full healed.
I don't know.
I don't trust myself.
It's okay.
My.
My two wives.
My two wives got this.
You guys got this.
Okay.
I'm scared.
It's
okay.
I think that can fix you.
I saw wife number two.
It's fine.
It's okay.
My lady.
She'll get better.
She'll.
She'll heal.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no... No, no, no... No, no, no, no... No, no, no, no, no... No, no, no, no... Yo...
Me and my two wives did it.
Oh, shit, did I call her out by her wrong name?
Oh, shit, It's okay.
She doesn't know that.
Oh my god, he's so small now.
Look at him.
Wife gone.
Think about wife.
Oh my god, look how small he is.
Oh my god, he's so skinny.
Look at him.
Oh my god.
He was not working on his arm game, that's for sure.
Miss wife.
Bird tree wards off all who Dane approach.
We are, we are all forsaken.
He was wearing like platform shoes, that's why it made him look so big.
Time to keep...
Oh sorry, my wife and my child, okay?
I'm like, how fuck was I supposed to know that jellyfish was now?
Like, look how big she is!
Okay, my wife and my child, all right?
All right, let's see, there she is!
There she is, officer!
What did I do?!
All right, let's see.
We go up now.
That was pretty easy.
Offer seed.
First off, well done.
Victory!
First off, but, and then don't give up.
Yay!
They're all congratulating me and my family!
All right, where is it?
Where's my favorite thing?
Where is it?
Where is...
Weak foe?
Where is it?
Oh, it's an enemies.
Okay, I got an idea.
Wait, I got an idea.
Where's his body?
Where's your fucking body?
All right.
Okay, and then...
Uh...
Oh, wait!
Sitting sideways!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Oh my god, pointing downward.
Oh my...
That's so good.
Right here.
Here we go.
First try.
Point down, not the point down.
Perfect.
Weak ass foe.
Door.
You don't have to write.
Oh, you don't have to write.
None in Pentro Forest refuse all.
Wait, but I...
What?!
But I did it!
I killed him!
How do I...
What do you mean?!
I literally killed this man!
Let me through!
Oh, I didn't press the grace.
Okay, wait.
Wait, what?
Oh, I can't kill him.
None may claim the title of elder lord.
Thy deeds shall be met with failure.
Just as I.
Oh.
I just touched the grace?
If I touch grace, what if he comes back alive?
I swear to god, if he comes back alive, I swear to him.
Oh, shit.
Hey!
I told you I didn't kill her!
Hello again.
I told you she's alive!
My wife!
Allow me a moment to converse with you.
You are unable to enter the Erd Tree.
No?
Prevented by the mantle of barbs.
The thorns are impenetrable.
Yeah.
A husk of the Erd Tree's being.
That spurns all that exists without.
That's my wife.
I told you she didn't die.
And become the Elden Hall.
I just started our little, like, nicknames for each other.
She's like, I'll call you friend, and that's it.
And I'll be like, oh, you're so silly, wife.
So I'd like you to undertake a new journey with me to the flame of ruin.
Far above the clouds, upon the snowy mountaintops of the giants.
Then, I can set the Erd Tree aflame and guide you down the path to becoming Elden Hall.
Oh my god, and then you'll be my queen, right?
You'll be my consort, right?
Right?
Shall I turn your runes to strong...
Oh my god, you want me to...
Hold my hand.
Oh my god.
We're on third base.
Your thoughts.
Oh!
My thoughts.
The principles you would follow.
See?
Look at that, guys.
Would a friend do that?
All right.
All right, guys.
What next?
What do we do next?
Oh my god, guys.
Guys, I gotta censor the hand-holding.
HP, vigor, endurance...
Uh...
Dexterity...
Arcane...
HP?
All right, we'll do HP.
Oh, I could do one HP, and then we could do something else, too.
And endurance next?
Okay, we don't need strength, though.
Isn't...
Isn't my build for dexterity?
Okay, we don't need faith.
We don't need to believe.
Arcane?
Do I do another arcane?
Uh...
Use best dexterity weapons?
So, do I...
Do I do strength, then?
But I'm not gonna use the spear.
I'm gonna use the katanas.
I like the katanas.
Arcane or...
Okay, I can do another...
More vigor.
Strength's still good?
Okay.
Believe in us, I believe in you.
We do believe in her, right?
Kevin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, uh...
Okay, I'll do one strength, then.
All right.
Nice.
We should find some more churches later.
I feel like...
I feel like maybe my heels are not that strong.
Why, he disappeared?
No!
How would my message make sense now?
Why did you disappear?
Now my message makes no sense.
I'm mad!
Here, that...
Where do I have to go next?
I guess they...
Here, right?
All right, what's this?
The road...
Road?
Is that where to go next?
Is it that?
Oh, okay.
It's this.
Okay, so...
Go to the middle of the area?
What?
What do you mean?
Is there anything else here?
Nothing else here.
All right.
Oh, so many people died here.
Fucking weak.
Skill issue.
Okay.
Then I guess I'll go...
Here.
Is it here?
Where even am I, anyway?
Yeah, here.
Okay.
Will I be able to get over...
No, I can't.
Main Street.
It's in the center?
What's...
Which is the center?
Wrong way?
Which one is it?
The Capital Rampire?
Avenue Balcony?
Avenue Balcony.
Oh, here.
I fought the giant tree?
Where did I fight it?
Oh, that guy.
I was like, where did I fight a giant tree?
Okay.
Okay, where do I walk though?
I walk from here?
Okay, left.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see if I can run past all of this guy again.
Okay, he's right behind me, isn't he?
Oh, I hear him.
I absolutely hear him.
It's okay.
If I keep running, it's like he's never here.
Go from here, or do I go straight?
Oh, he's still following me.
Oh, no.
Out of my head?
Don't worry.
Oh, he's gone.
No, he's just slowly heading over.
Never mind.
He is not gone.
He's just very, very slowly coming.
Oh, hey.
Hello there.
Okay.
These guys are weak, so it's fine.
Hey, guys.
Get out of here.
This is my dead body.
That's fucking right.
Leave!
Okay, and then I'll go this way.
Oh, they're praying to something up here.
Oh, shit.
I knew it.
I was like, I should lock on to see if there's anything hiding.
I know my Elden Ring.
I knew you were hiding.
I see you.
Oh, you were sleeping.
He was like, he was like, what do you mean?
I was just trying to sleep.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
He's like, what do you mean you're sleeping?
All right.
Nice.
Oh, my lantern.
You're right.
Now I see everything.
Okay, there's people up here.
Oh, wait.
There's a lot of people up here.
Wait, what the fuck?
Okay, maybe I should summon something here.
Yeah, this guy.
Holy shit.
Hey!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay, never mind.
Oh, my.
He beat up my child.
I'm like, never mind, sir.
Oh, I'm sorry!
That's gonna be like, hey, stop beating up my child!
I'm like, never mind, sir.
Never mind.
Go do your thing if you want to.
Okay.
Jesus!
Holy shit!
He does so much damage!
Okay.
There we go.
All right, one down.
Who are they praying to?
All right.
I should float heal just in case.
Oh my God, please, get down from here.
All right, nice.
Oh!
Not nice!
This is not a good thing to do.
Guys, it's very mean.
Very, very, very mean.
Okay, nice.
Let's get rid of magic man.
Wait, he fucking healed?
That's legal!
You don't have the right tool!
Okay.
I'll break your fucking shield.
I don't care.
Get out.
Get out!
That's right!
No God can help you now!
Oops.
That's fucking right.
Pray to no one!
Okay, they're all dead.
All right, nice.
I got the butterfly.
I got the powder.
Got the old fang.
Then I'll grab this.
Nice.
All right, I guess we go forward now?
Yeah.
We go forward.
First off, Earth Tree.
Is there anything here?
Climb on the spot.
All of them.
We're jumping off.
Bloody, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You'll probably want 20 arcane eventually.
You want to use one...
Oh!
Okay.
All right, up we go.
My wife told me to go up.
And I listen.
Because I'm a good husband.
There should be a grace ahead soon.
Oh my god.
A video popped up in my feed of this guy doing a capitalism, um, elder ring run.
Where every step you take, uh, requires, like, money.
Like, every single move you do requires money.
That shit was crazy.
And then it scales, too.
So, like, at first it was, like, one...
It costs, like, one, uh, rune every time you walk.
And then the more, the richer you get, the richer you get, the more money it costs.
And then when you die...
When you die, you lose, like, you lose all your money.
So you're, like, stuck in place.
And he made his character, Jeff Bezos.
What a fuck shot?
Oh my god.
I did not realize you existed, sir.
Don't worry.
Now you're just like them.
Dead.
Why did it say left side or somebody?
Like, who's on my left?
Also, I'm a little worried that, um...
I'm a little worried that there's no grace near me.
Oh.
Hey.
Oh!
Oh, shit!
That's what he meant by be wary of left!
That's what he...
Why didn't I just walk over you?
I didn't need to summon him!
It's okay.
Surely, I'm faster than a horse.
He's shy!
It's okay.
I can do the serpentine.
Did he give up?
Oh, he got tired.
The horse got tired.
Right.
That's good of him.
I don't like how there's a lot of bloodstains here.
What's wrong with the horse?
I just want to make sure there's nothing here.
Why are there bloodstains all over this area?
Cellar ahead.
Praise the tarnish.
Praise the high road.
Stupid horse.
Wow,
this is very awfully dark.
Is there Grace here?
Guys?
Guys, is there Grace here?
I need to know before I go down here.
Guys, it looks so safe.
Grace, the thing is...
I don't know why I don't, like, trust you.
When you said that...
For some reason, that did not...
Sound accurate.
Because it was scary and dark down there.
What do you mean, why did I go back?
Did you not see the same room as I did?
Did this room not look scary and dark to you?
Like, why did I go back?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, hey.
Great citizen.
Oh my god.
You guys were telling the truth.
For once.
How did this guy die?
Alright, what do I level up?
Alright, I'm gonna use the bathroom and chat.
You guys decide amongst yourselves.
Uh, and nominate a spokesperson on what to upgrade next.
I'll be right back.
I need some bathroom.
Alright, I'm back.
Did you guys nominate your one?
Your one?
Your spokesperson?
Faith or Riot?
Alright.
We unanimously decided on faith.
I am the one.
Okay, I'm reading through this.
Who will?
Who will speak for you guys?
Who speaks for you guys, to be your spokesperson?
Absolutely not faith.
Oh, you're not unanimous, guys.
Anything that's not faith.
Wow, I can't believe it.
You're not even a hive mind, guys.
I speak for the drag group.
We nominate that.
Apparently, apparently.
There's no unanimous decision in the end.
So, the trial is now a mistrial.
The trial shall now be extended.
Alright.
Okay, arcane, then.
We'll do arcane.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where am I?
Where actually am I?
Yeah.
We already did my one boss, anyway.
So, like, I can technically just end stream here.
But we won't.
We won't.
We'll keep going.
I did, but... I'm just saying.
We technically did do our one story boss.
Alan is a false prophet.
Do not listen to him.
Where is the fucking map?
Oh, my God.
They're everywhere.
I'm so fucking lost.
Oh, my God.
I almost fucking rode off.
I'm trying to figure out where to go.
I got a butterfly.
It's so disorienting.
Try the high road?
Wait.
What's that over there?
It's not the high road.
Okay.
No.
Oh.
Someone says high.
It says high.
Oh, my God.
It's a troll, isn't it?
I'm not.
I'm not fighting that.
This area is so fucking dangerous.
Oh, my God.
There was poison.
Ah!
I don't know how...
Okay.
That works.
I don't know how I live, but I live...
Nice recovery.
I don't know how I did it.
Oh, my God.
It's so dark.
What can I say?
I'm just a gamer.
Hee-hee.
Nice.
We need that golden seed.
I guess we just go up.
Oh, now it's the high road.
Okay.
There's clearly, like, people on me because I can't do anything.
What does it say?
Friend ahead?
First off, dashing through.
Weak foe ahead.
Okay, guys.
Is it friend?
I don't think that was friend.
Oh, yeah.
That's...
Hmm.
Okay.
There must be a grace nearby, though.
Whoa!
Shh!
I don't super hope.
Oh, my God.
Oh, thank God.
The statue was next there.
Thank you.
I was like, maybe I can dash through him.
There must be a grace ahead.
Oh, there is a grace ahead.
Wow.
Wowee.
Oh.
Surely he'll disappear, right?
Surely he doesn't...
Oh.
Oh, he'll get tired.
Oh!
He didn't get tired.
He didn't get tired, guys!
He's not tired!
He's still coming at me!
Guys, surely he'll get tired, right?
Surely...
Surely he'll decide...
Surely he'll be done, right?
Wait, where is he?
Oh!
He got tired!
Oh, my God!
He actually did get tired!
He's actually EP!
Oh, he's EP!
I didn't hear no bell!
Oh, my God!
He got EP!
Thank God!
Okay, now...
Now I can fight you!
All right.
Okay, now...
Now we can be friends.
We can be friends now.
Where is he?
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Child.
Okay.
Okay, now...
Now...
Now we can do the real fight.
Oh, my God.
He does so much.
Wow.
Oh, my God!
What the fuck?
Oh, what the fuck did he do?
What did he do to me?
Holy shit!
What the fuck was that?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, it was one attack.
Okay.
That...
That was a little wild.
That was...
This wouldn't have happened if you had me.
I just didn't believe hard enough, apparently, guys.
If only I started believing.
Where is my runes?
Oh, there it is.
We'll just head for it.
That'll be fine.
It'll be fine, right?
Oh.
Don't worry, my little...
Ay, ay, ay.
My little jellyfish.
She'll be so healthy.
I really, really believe.
All right.
Okay.
Clearly, I don't know.
Oh, my God.
I...
Guys, I don't know if I want to fight him anymore.
I figure it's always good investment.
Corby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm starting to believe less and less.
I...
I'm starting to not believe anymore.
It's getting a little harder to believe.
I don't know why.
Like...
I don't know.
He seems a little bullshit.
Just a little bit.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Yeah, this...
Oh, my jellyfish!
Holy shit!
Bro!
Oh, my God!
He wasn't even allowed to live!
Okay.
You know, like...
I would have been fine if, like...
I...
If, like...
I'm allowed to have, like, a little...
If my jellyfish was able to live, like, one second, at least.
But I don't even think, like...
Oh, my God!
Guys, I think we'll come back another time.
Don't worry.
We'll come back.
I swear to God, guys.
We'll come back another time.
And then she never came back.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, guys.
We'll come back.
I swear.
We'll come back and say hello to them in another time.
Don't worry, guys.
Hello.
You want to touch my hand?
Yeah?
You like my fingers?
My dad said the same thing.
The first sin?
What's the second or third?
Doing so will unbind destiny's death and slay the world itself.
What's around that?
Who would dare put you up to such a task?
My beautiful wife.
Most certainly not the fingers.
My wife's...
Am I Shrek?
What am I...
Oh no, it was Shrek.
I can't...
I'm like...
Am I supposed to be Shrek right now?
Okay.
Let's go just burn the tree for my wife.
Alright.
The grand lift of Rod.
Oh, it's a medallion.
Look at my beautiful medallion that my wife gave me.
It's all over.
Oh?
What's going on?
Oh!
Puppies!
Kevin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Second sin is Pokemon card style.
There it is.
Adultery.
I'm just scanning my...
My...
Uh...
My little badge here.
My fob.
Yay!
I've got my uppies!
Oh!
There's the tree!
I'm gonna burn that tree down and then my wife will marry me.
I got what's down here.
Okay.
Oh, hey.
An item.
Skellum, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
The upcoming NPC is 100% telling the truth and more trustworthy than dad.
Oh.
Upcoming NPC.
Who it's gonna be.
How do I get back up?
Okay.
Oh, it's from here.
Yeah.
Call her wife now.
Cause it's our little fun nickname.
She tells me to stop.
But then I know she's just kidding.
Tells me.
She's like, stop.
We're friends.
And then that's her cute nickname for me, guys.
She calls me friend and I call her wife.
Oh, I was gonna say, can I kill it?
Oh, is that the map?
Oh, yeah.
I got the map.
Nice.
Okay, so I have to go here next.
Look, we held hands.
We're like, literally married.
We just don't have the papers yet.
Because, like, that's just a formal thing.
But informally, we held hands.
And that means marriage.
Alright.
Is it him?
Is that the friend?
Are you ready?
Enemy?
Or friend?
He's covering his face.
I fear that you were previously acquainted with this vessel.
Well.
That is most unfortunate.
For he is dead.
Oh.
As for his flesh.
He gave it to me.
Shabriri.
I hope you can make your peace with that.
You were about to sacrifice something precious.
The life of a fair maiden.
That you would toss into the fiery forge.
No.
He's my wife.
What a horrible thing to ponder.
Your ascendancy requires her sacrifice.
Whether she wishes at all.
I will never.
I will never throw her into the fiery pits.
Lies!
Chosen, tarnished.
And would be.
Dare to tread the path of true rigor.
Spare.
The poor girl.
Heaven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you are prepared to show resolve.
And attain lordship through righteous hardship.
Then heed the words of I.
Shabriri.
What is it?
Chosen, tarnished.
And would be lord.
Descend into the depths far below the eardtree capital.
Seek audience with the three fingers.
And the flame of frenzy.
If you inherit the flame of frenzy.
Your flesh will serve as kindling.
And the girl.
Can be spared.
Setting you on the righteous path of lordship.
The path of the lord of chaos.
Burn the eardtree to the ground.
That's what I'm gonna do.
And incinerate all that divides and distinguishes.
Ah, may chaos take the world.
Oh my god.
Take the world.
Chosen, tarnished.
And would be lord.
Descend into the depths.
Okay, so.
He wants me to do that.
And then my beautiful wife will live.
Sage and thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Ah, may chaos take the world.
Yeah, he's just been really liking the chaos shit.
Okay, so.
He said the thing.
My wife has something to tell me.
Oh, wife.
Oh.
Okay.
I go talk to my wife now.
Wife time, wife time.
Yay.
Wait, where's my...
Wait, where's the grace for this?
I don't...
Oh, I skipped the grace.
My grace was all the way back there.
Wife time, wife time.
Hello, wife.
Oh, make sure you don't burn.
Oh, my God.
I forgot he's, like, right next to the grace.
There is something I'd like to say.
Yeah?
My purpose was given to me by my mother.
But now...
I act of my own volition.
I have set my heart upon the world that I would have.
Regardless of my mother's designs.
I won't allow anyone to speak ill of that.
Not even you.
Oh?
Don't worry, wife.
I'll make sure nothing bad happens to you.
Because I love you.
And we're in love.
And we're gonna live happily ever after.
My wife.
Wait, so do I kill him?
I want to actually kill him for, like, his armor.
Yes.
Oh, I get a new katana?
But is it, like, a good katana?
Is it a better katana?
Oh, I get...
It doesn't affect the story?
I swear to God.
Because I will do it.
I don't get the katana here?
Oh, okay.
I guess I don't do it.
You guys just don't want me to kill people.
That's fucked up.
I just want me to kill people for the sake.
Look, look.
I kill people, but, like...
I do it because I want something in return.
I don't do it just...
Oh, shit!
I don't do it just for fun.
I also do it for, like, their items.
That's different.
Oh, my God.
Why is she so strong?
She is so strong!
Yeah, I don't kill for free, guys.
I need to get something in return.
Okay, I need to summon jellyfish here.
She is actually really strong.
Yeah, I...
If I'm gonna commit murder, I might as well commit theft as well.
Like, you know?
Because it's like...
Because, like, if I'm gonna commit all the crime...
I might as well commit all the other...
Rest of the crime.
Too.
Because I already...
I already went that far.
So it only makes sense.
Okay, I definitely need to upgrade that...
Uh...
Oh, my God.
I need to find churches.
I need to get a church.
I...
Okay, there we go.
Oh, there's a...
Belly right here.
Right?
It's not a church?
No.
Fuck!
I thought that was a church.
Or it's a church up here.
Hello?
Oh, God.
There's so many of them.
They're so strong.
There's way too many of them.
Wait.
Right here?
Right where?
Which one is the church?
I mean, that's the...
Wait.
Where am I?
Go underground?
Yeah?
No.
Wait.
Yeah?
Where the hole...
Where there's a hole, there's a goal.
There's no holes.
I'm looking for all the holes.
Where are my holes?
Where am I going?
Oh, through the ruins?
Oh, so I just keep going from here.
But I gotta avoid the maidens, because the maidens are scary.
My body is only for my wife.
Be gone!
Be gone, wretched whores!
This body is only for my wife!
My beautiful wife that held my hand!
That's right!
Whoa!
Oh, that's...
That's a hole.
No enemy ahead?
Something ahead?
Okay, guys.
You can't be like, no enemy ahead, and then something ahead.
Oh, nice.
Whoa!
Whoa?
Oh, no.
He triggered...
Oh, no!
I can't get out!
Oh, I can't.
What's this?
Oh.
Then my jellyfish fell.
I think my jellyfish fell down.
Okay, so we have the stones now.
It's okay, I can...
Oh!
I can go this way.
Alright.
Leave now.
Oh!
Hmm...
Maybe I should just...
You know, I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna go back to the grace first, actually.
I'm just gonna go to the table.
Real quick.
Look at that.
I saved my stuff from...
Or my wife.
I'll give the bell to the...
To the ladies.
There you go.
Yay!
I'll upgrade my sword, too.
Uh...
Oh my god!
She can upgrade my jellyfish!
Nah?
Oh, I can't.
Fuck!
I don't have the grave gloves.
Whatever.
Okay.
I just need smithing stone 5.
Okay, I can afford that.
Should be able to afford that.
I just bought the stone.
Yeah, but I don't need Margaret's sword.
I have katanas.
There you go.
This is what we needed.
Yeah, buy five...
I have katanas.
Would Margaret have katanas?
Well, he doesn't.
So, um...
Checkmate.
I forgot I need runes to do this.
I am...
Okay, wait.
I have one more...
Yeah, I had this.
Three thousand.
There you go.
Yeah, which one's...
No, this is my OG sword.
Okay, nice.
Alright, I'll talk to the boss.
So...
I'll talk to...
Three toes.
You managed to return.
You know what this means.
The earth tree has burned you.
The fingers...
Remain still...
Shaken...
By this turn of events.
They are busy...
Consulting the Kratos will.
When they are finished...
The fingers will again...
Offer their guidance.
But thousands...
If not tens of thousands...
Of moons must first pass.
No matter for me.
But you...
How will you...
Ever manage to wait?
My...
Oh...
Uh...
What's this?
Yeah, see?
Those aren't katanas!
I know a katana when I see one.
Or this non-katana.
Holy shit, wait.
Their armor is pretty...
Wait, do I...
Take their armor though?
Wait, their armor is pretty...
Is their armor better than what I have?
That is generally good, but it's heavy?
Oh!
Oh, okay.
I'll grab his armor then.
But I didn't have money though.
I don't have money.
No money.
Heavens forbid.
That is not the domain of mere men.
The burning of the earth tree is the first cardinal sin.
And you...
Why is it the first?
There's so many worse things I could do.
The rune of death, too.
The rune of death goes...
The other...
Is destined death.
The forbidden shadow plucked from the golden order upon its creation.
Unleashing the rune now would be unthinkable.
The fingers would never permit it.
Nor would the greater will.
Why not?
But here we are.
So then I can be your guide if I kill that guy.
...seving our link to the greater will.
In ruins...
Impossible events transpire beyond the ken of the fingers.
Who is to say that the cardinal sin must be cardinal forever?
Go on.
Finish the job.
See?
She wants me to do it.
Take the course you deem most worthy.
That's right.
I'm gonna do it.
How do I burn the thorns?
You must find kindling.
Only the smoldering flame in the great forge of the giants on the highest peak in the lands between can burn the earth tree.
She's like, you can't do it.
It's a sin.
Anyway, it would be pretty cool.
But special kindling is required to reignite the flame.
She believes in me.
For the flame to burn the earth tree.
A sacrifice is needed.
Of one who envisions the flame.
And can lead you to the ruin of death.
Okay, so...
That's how you burn the thorns.
Alright.
We can head over...
Back here now.
Now we can keep going.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna do it for my wife.
A beautiful wife.
Who also loves me very, very much, guys.
She said if I do all of this...
She imp...
Okay, she didn't say it.
But she implied...
That if I do all of that, then we can officially get married.
I...
I read all...
I read it from her body language.
Oh, she knows.
She knows.
She implied that she knew.
What?
Oh, I heard something.
Alright.
Oh, hey.
Is there like a...
Dungeon nearby?
Oh, hello.
Oh, my God!
I was like, hello, birdies.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
That's it.
You're gonna be endangered.
I don't care.
I don't care if you're on the list.
Oh, my God.
Fucking...
You stupid bird.
You're actually such a stupid bird.
You're such a stupid bird!
Holy...
Why is this bird so fucking tanky?
I don't care if these birds are on the list.
Huh?
Oh, there's a...
There should be a dungeon nearby.
Where did it point to?
Like this way?
Oh, my God.
There's so many of them.
It's like the bald eagles.
Where you're not supposed to disturb their habitat.
Because they're...
Um...
Endangered.
I'm gonna finish the job.
I...
I will finish the job.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
What?
Toki, is this finishing the job?
I will.
I...
Guys, give me a sec.
Oh, my God.
Where the fuck is the wife?
It's the husband.
Oh, my God.
He's gonna finish the job.
Oh,
my God.
I
do not know where the fuck that bird came from.
Oh, my God.
That...
Did anyone get his license plate?
That bird came out of fucking nowhere.
I swear to God.
Okay.
I'm not finishing anything, clearly.
Wanna know what...
If there's anything here.
But there's nothing here.
What the fuck?
Why was there, like, an indent here?
That's so weird.
There was, like, an indent here.
I swear to God, it...
Oh, my God.
That...
That was the wrong move.
I was trying to get off this horse.
Are you serious?
He was one HP.
Oh, my God.
Get out of here.
That really is...
No, it's not.
I knew it.
Fucking knew that was not a secret path.
Wait, what?
That's 2,000.
Oh, my God.
2,000 people?
Are you serious?
I can't believe it.
It has 2,000 votes.
And I'm continuing the cycle.
I'm...
I'm gonna continue the cycle.
It has 2,001 votes now.
Just one burn.
Goddamn, fuck you.
Wait, what's over here?
Wait, what?
What path is this?
Am I supposed to go this pathway?
Wait.
Is it this way, or...
This is another path.
There's another path, like...
Here.
Oh, that's for the dungeon?
Okay.
What... Where does this go?
Is this...
Story or dungeon?
Oh, that's the main path.
Oh.
Okay.
So, what about this path over here?
Wait.
Oh, no.
That is the main path.
Sorry.
I got...
There's no other path.
I'm sorry.
I'm going...
Crazy.
There's no other...
There's no other path.
That was the main path.
That was the same path, guys.
Oh, shit.
That's a lot of people.
Oh, no.
I got two in my head.
Oh, here?
Oh, hey.
Oh, there's a dungeon.
Found the dungeon.
How did he die?
Oh.
That's how.
Wait.
What do you mean oh, no?
Oh, wait.
This is a dungeon full of suffering?
Wait.
No.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh!
No.
No!
Yes.
Okay.
Come on, get over here.
Are you serious?
It goes through your fucking friend?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Catch us.
Fucker.
Okay, there's the be wary part.
Okay.
Level seven.
Oh my gosh.
I skipped level six somewhere.
It's really his buddy has to be somewhere.
I knew it.
I knew his buddy would be here somewhere.
Man, I see you.
I see you.
What?
What the fuck was that range?
Okay.
Alright, let's grab this guy out.
Just to be safe.
I know there was no message there, but just to be safe.
How did you die?
That's good to know.
Wait, what the fuck?
How did he die?
Oh shit, I forgot to grab that plant.
Okay, he did it.
Oh my god, this is a deep asshole.
Yeah, no wonder she fucking died.
Try it down.
What?
Try underground?
First off, so to speak require- Oh.
Okay, fucking liars.
What the fuck do you- Oh!
Oh!
What the fuck am I supposed to get down from there?
Okay, we'll go to the secret passage.
Alright.
Oh my god, this is a deep asshole too.
Okay, there's no more messages here.
So I assume that this is the right place.
Why is there so many dead- Oh my god.
What the fuck is that?
Trap required a head?
There's a trap?
Guys, I don't think that's friendly.
Oh!
What?
Oh my god!
What do you mean?
I think it's just really, really friendly.
Okay, what the fuck does it- I did it!
What the fuck?
Oh, this is what he means.
Oh my god.
I think he's stuck.
Wait, I think he's stuck.
I...
I'm so sad.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Why is it all traps?
Oh my god, of course.
Oh my god.
Because of course they are.
Oh, of course they're there.
Okay, we'll just wait.
Okay, let's get these guys out of here first.
Okay.
Where the fuck do I?
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Attacking.
Range battle ahead.
Run, run, run.
Peekaboo!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Do you think he knows?
No, I already got it.
How do I...
What the fuck do I do?
Okay.
Maybe he'll go through the trap.
Maybe he'll touch the trap.
Maybe he'll touch it.
Oh my god.
No.
No, no, no.
Come back.
Oh please, come back.
Okay.
Just keep blowing on him.
Just keep blowing.
Oh my god, it's frozen.
Oh my god, no!
I fucking fucked it up again!
Come back up!
Just keep blowing.
Stay frosty.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Please just die!
Please!
Just die!
Oh my god, he's what?
Oh my god.
3,000, that's all I get.
I just get 3,000.
Oh my god, that's actually all I get.
That's it.
That's all I get?
I just...
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, that's cool.
That's cool.
Alright.
Oh my god, how did he get there?
How the fuck did he get back there?
Maybe it'll touch him.
Oh nice, it did.
Oh nice, he doesn't know.
We'll just slowly kill him.
That's fine.
Oh my god, I almost walked into that.
Not even a lousy shirt.
I can wait.
I can't... I can wait.
I'm patient.
We'll just wait.
We'll wait here.
Oh you're fine.
Nice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Come on.
That's just two more hits.
The hardest battle of my life.
Oh my god, what a fight.
Truly was the fight of our generation.
Right there.
The 1v1.
Of a lifetime.
It's over here.
In this.
Wow, Doki.
What a gamer.
Truly the gamer of our generation.
Right here.
Okay.
Was that really it?
That's everything down here?
I guess I should go back and grab some more meds.
Yeah, I was gonna sit.
That's it?
Okay, so I have to call...
I should call down the other thing.
No, I meant like the secret path.
Wait, how do I...
Okay, I should do that then.
No, I meant the path down there.
No, I meant the...
The secret path down there.
Was that everything in the secret path?
Down there?
Wait, there's more?
What did I miss?
Wait, what did I miss in the secret path?
Oh, the secret was the...
Okay, I got everything in there.
Okay, I'm gonna grab...
I'm gonna grab...
Get meds.
And then like head down for the other...
Yeah, I went under the...
The dungeon area.
I wanna...
Okay, I'm gonna go get my meds.
Wait, wait a minute.
This way.
Alright.
We'll go more for the dungeon.
Because I have zero HP now.
Alright.
No, I just...
I have zero...
Flask.
So I'm just getting my flask before I do this.
Actually, I don't have to kill them.
Okay.
Okay, now I do have to...
Now I will kill them.
Okay.
Now I will.
I wasn't thinking about it before.
But now I have to.
Now it's serious.
Yeah.
It was this way.
I got lost somehow.
Yeah.
Now it's personal.
Alright.
Down we go.
Down, down, down, down.
Dots are down.
Then it's this way.
And then left.
Wait, can I equip one more talisman?
I didn't even notice that.
Oh, I can!
What do I have on?
Uh...
Raises focus.
Raises vitality.
Critical elements.
All sound made by the wearer.
Oh.
I like vitality.
Vitality is always nice.
Wait, actually, what the fuck does vitality mean?
Wait, I'm like...
Wait, I don't think...
I'm like, wait a minute.
What does vitality even mean?
Okay, I like focus.
That's...
Oh my god.
What the fuck am I...
What does focus do?
What do you do?
Wait, wait.
Okay, give me a sec.
Yeah, I kept thinking...
Vitality...
Um...
Is like, vigor.
But I was like, oh wait, that's not it.
Blue dagger?
This?
It's the critical hit?
Oh, no insta-death?
I like that.
Oh, it's PvP.
Okay.
And I'll just...
I'll just do this one then.
I'll just do the critical hit shit.
What the fuck?
They can throw shit now?
Well, that's not fair.
Oh my god.
This is not your fight!
That's it.
This is now your fight.
That's fucking it.
You could've stayed in your lane.
Alright.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here!
Alright, down we go.
Down, down, down.
Down we go.
No down ahead.
Okay, that's good to know.
What does this say?
Liar ahead and then no horse ahead.
Wait, who's the liar?
Okay, yeah.
I'm pretty sure there's no down ahead.
Like, who's the liar?
Liar ahead.
Oh, hey.
Good pot?
Good pot or bad pot?
Good pot.
Bad pot.
That's a very bad pot.
That's fucking right.
I know what you are!
We're dashing through.
Ambush ahead.
Where's the ambush?
Oh my god!
Wait.
I think he's too fat.
Wait a minute.
For what?
Wait, no.
All of this is too big.
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
Give me a...
Never mind.
He can't...
He can go through all of this.
Wait, unless...
I don't think he goes...
Wait, okay.
Okay, wait.
I figured this out.
Mike!
Thank you for the...
To get the shits.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
What am I gonna do with this giant nice pot?
What's over here?
Oh my god, it's a little baby.
Little baby is following me.
I don't think he can fit up here.
Yeah, I was right.
I was right.
Alright, that was my bad.
I literally walked into that trap.
I walked into that.
Who's lying?
I can't tell who's lying!
Who's telling the truth?
And who's not?
I don't know!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
It'll explode, right?
Where is it?
Okay, there you go.
This way.
And then we'll just run here.
Wait.
This?
What's wrong with this little guy?
I don't wanna deal with this little guy.
I feel like this little guy is gonna be a big little guy.
Which one's the boss?
What's the worst that could happen?
A lot of things!
I don't know.
Oh my god, I'm gonna get poisoned.
I'm gonna get poisoned.
I got too cocky.
I'll just walk past this.
I'll just walk past it.
That's fine.
I don't need to fight all of that.
That's...
That's fine.
Oh my god!
Why is there so many a pot?
What?
Good pot or bad pot?
Good pot.
Wait, what's down here?
I don't know if I should go down there.
Everything seems dangerous.
Okay, okay.
That's a big boy.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Oh, I can kill him!
Yeah.
That's fucking right.
Crack.
Yoink!
My loot now.
I'm a genius.
I didn't notice it, but I'm a genius.
Alright, down we go.
Oh, it's here again.
Wait, where do I go after that?
Wait, there's no lever down here.
Wait, what?
This is where the pot guy was before.
Isn't it?
Oh no, this is new!
Okay.
Still no lever, still no lever.
Lever ahead, therefore seek down.
Wait, where am I?
Wait, what?
Oh!
I go down!
There's a big-ass pot.
I'm faster, I'm faster, I'm faster, I'm faster, I'm faster.
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god!
Children!
Okay.
Okay, it's this way.
And then...
Go up.
Bye.
Okay, we did it.
We got the pot.
We did it.
Alright, now we can fight the boss.
And not the children.
Oh my god.
The scariest thing in the world.
It will go up.
I know I need to press a button to cancel, but I'm scared I'm going to accidentally fall off.
Let me make sure I'm at the top first before I do anything else.
Uh...
No, no, I want to get my potions back before I do the thing.
I'm just getting my potions back.
Alright.
How much do I need for upgrade?
I know I don't have any souls on me right now.
Or runes on me.
A 37.
I can farm that here.
I'll farm that here.
Cause like...
I don't want to lose all of it in the middle of the boss fight.
So I'll just farm it here.
Yeah, how much do they give again?
Okay, they give...
Oh yeah, that's like almost 1k each.
That's fine.
There we go.
Alright, get over here.
And if I die here, at least I'm dying next to the stuff, though.
Okay.
Alright, get over here.
That's right!
Oh fuck.
Alright, nice.
That's 30...
32, and then I'll reset you.
I'll talk to her after I level up, so I can hold her hand.
Alright.
I just gotta do this like...
3 more times.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
And then...
Get over here.
I need your souls!
Get over here!
That's fucking right!
Defeated!
Your purpose here is to level me up!
That's right!
That's your only purpose!
No, I don't have any, uh...
Runesos on me.
Alright.
One more last time.
While I'm doing the last level up fight...
Pick my next thing to level up, guys.
Decide amongst yourself.
The Council of Dragoons!
Figure it out!
Figure out what...
Oh shit!
Council of Dragoons!
Figure out what I need to do next!
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Oh, yeah.
Fuck that one guy in particular.
That's right.
Get out of here.
Alright.
I have enough now.
Alright, what did you guys decide?
Oh wait, I don't have enough.
Fuck!
I need one more!
I need a...
Nevermind!
You still have more time!
I need one more!
Apparently.
I'm just missing one more.
Okay, now I have enough.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright.
Alright!
Which one is it?
Vigor?
I see Vigor and Arcane.
Vigor or Arcane?
Arcane.
Uh...
Oh my god, you're right!
I can talk to her and then she'll hold my hand.
Think not of the kindling.
I shall see to that.
All I ask of you is to make the journey to the snowy mountain tops of the giants.
Far above the clouds.
I know.
I'm asking you to commit a cardinal sin.
Oh baby, I'll sin for you.
I'll eat that apple for you.
As long as you hold my hand.
Fuck!
Wait, does she come back?
Does she come back?
No!
I was gonna...
I was gonna take off my gloves.
I thought...
No!
I fumbled!
God!
No!
I was gonna take off my gloves!
I...
Oh!
It's my chance!
I fumbled!
Yes!
My wife!
Okay.
Arcane or bigger?
What did we decide on?
No!
I can't believe I fumbled it!
I can't believe it!
She was right there!
Okay, I see arcane.
I can't believe it.
I have to level up by myself.
Like a maidenless fool.
Alright, we are this way.
Oh!
Shit!
Oh my god, bro.
Fuck this, actually.
Fuck this.
I'm resetting this dungeon.
Like, you can chase me all you want, but I'm resetting this dungeon.
Alright.
Reset we go.
Wait, is that thing still in me?
What the fuck?
Fumbled it like a maidenless scrub!
I can't believe I fumbled it!
I squandered it!
Okay, I wanna make sure I don't use any of my MP for this.
Okay.
Jeez, what?
That still hit me?
Really?
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
I missed you?
Okay.
I'm just gonna heal up right now.
Are you serious?
Oh my god!
Okay, that's it.
Get out of here!
It's not overkill!
I deserve this!
Alright, now we can fucking go to the boss room now.
Jesus Christ, there's a knife sticking out of my arm.
Alright, I don't know...
What this boss fight is gonna be like.
So...
We're gonna have a little safety message real quick.
There we go.
Head ahead.
First off, well done.
Monstrosity?
Wait, who the fuck are we fighting?
Who is that ugly?
Ugly.
Where is this ugly man?
Oh my god.
He is very ugly.
Oh my god!
I'm sorry for calling you ugly.
I'm so sorry.
Alright.
Hahaha!
Be careful of who you called ugly in high school!
What the fuck?
What...
What is this?
I'm so confused.
I'm...
It's just all bodies.
It's just bodies.
I...
I can't see anything.
It literally...
It's just body.
Hahaha!
He takes up, like, 80% of my screen.
Okay.
Like, I'm just so confused.
It's fine.
Okay, let's go, let's go, let's go.
I'm like, oh, shit!
I was like, you gotta hit me.
I'm like, right, I'm below him.
Guys, he indeed, he's hitting me.
Guys, he is indeed hitting me right now.
I am low-key very confused, though.
I can't...
Like, he takes up so much of my screen that I'm just...
I'm so confused.
I'm like, I feel like I can't dodge just because of how fucking...
Just how much he takes.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
There we go.
He's...
He's so low.
Please!
He was so low!
Oh my god, are you serious?
Please.
Oh my god, I got him!
Oh!
Thank god!
Nice.
A gold seed.
Let's go.
Oh wait, I got a chest, too!
Yay!
Chest!
Wait, what the fuck?
Why do I get a death root?
Alright, let's go back.
I'll laugh for a seed.
Hey, but it is a golden seed.
It is a golden seed, though.
I'll get to level up again.
Alright.
Vigor.
Dexterity.
Arcane strength.
Alright.
I got P. So, discuss amongst yourself.
My dragoon council.
Alright.
What have you decided?
Arcane?
Alright.
Arcane till 20 and then more endurance.
Okay.
The council has spoken.
Alright, we leave now.
We did our job.
Alright, off we go.
We're out to see the wizard.
The wonderful wizard of Oz.
I'm gonna get the jellyfish here, because I don't trust myself.
Kill him first.
You think he knows?
I think he knew.
Okay.
And then...
Get rid of these guys.
The little guys.
And then...
I'll get rid of the little guys.
Because I feel like...
The little guys will help the big man.
If, like, he, they know.
Like, I have a feeling.
Okay.
Alright.
What the fuck?
You're alive?
I was just swinging my...
My sword for decoration.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That is...
Oh, my God.
My child's gonna die soon.
He is so strong.
Wait, he is so strong.
He is so...
Oh, my God.
He has a fucking whip.
My child's dead.
But, like...
Yo!
Ah!
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
He is so strong.
I didn't think he'd be that strong.
Ah!
Holy fuck.
Okay.
Maybe I can cheese it a little bit.
Maybe?
Guys, I can't cheese it.
I can't cheese it.
It has...
It has blood.
It has bleed.
I thought bleed was a me thing.
Oh, my God.
That's a fire!
Damn!
Oh, my God.
I'm fucking dead.
My jellyfish sacrificed herself.
For this.
That's starting to stand.
Oh, my God.
It doesn't stop.
It doesn't stop!
Holy...
Oh, my God!
Oh!
Bro, what else can she do?
Okay.
I don't know why I did all that.
Holy shit.
I don't know how none of that hit me.
That was crazy.
None of that hit me.
Okay.
First off.
I don't know why none of that hit me there.
But I'll take it.
I'm not gonna run because I feel that if I start running, I'll fall off.
Oh, I can't take this.
Wait, is that... Does that guy have an arrow?
Okay, let's pull here first.
Okay, that guy has an arrow.
That guy gonna shoot me?
Oh, please don't.
Still so lonely.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm running.
I'm running.
I'm... I'm running.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please go faster.
Oh, thank god.
He hit the wall.
We're alive.
Oh...
No!
Shit!
Oh god.
We're still alive.
Okay, we'll just go this way.
Oh.
Saw my life flash before me right there.
Oh, thank god there's a grace here.
Nice.
A broken bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki will beat a boss in the first try.
But we'll get bodied by a rat for like 20 easily...
Easily avoidable deaths.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, we're safe now.
We're pretty safe here.
In these lands.
I feel oakly-dokly.
Where do I go, though?
Why is there ghost trees?
Who killed these ghost trees?
Who made these trees in them?
What kind of unfinished business do these trees have?
Lover or lover.
Sound?
Yeah, but what kind of unfinished business do they have?
They become a ghost because they have unfinished business.
They're a fucking tree.
You know that?
Get up.
I go right?
Guys, right or left?
I'm gonna avoid that.
To grow.
I didn't let them grow.
I'm going right.
I'm gonna fight these guys.
Why is he red?
I have red eyes.
Oh shit.
I'm just gonna ride my horse.
I feel like there's no reason to walk.
Is he sleeping or dead?
He lies many mysteries.
Can't tell if he's breathing.
I assume he must be sleeping.
Maybe they're nice.
In the land of Elden Ring?
Yeah.
Sure.
They're either crazy or they're here to kill me.
There's no in between.
Oh hey.
Oh that's cool.
And see like...
What am I looking at though?
So beautiful.
Oh there's the tree!
Story path is...
South?
Oh so this way.
That makes sense.
I have to go this way and then...
Like this and...
Wait how do I get up here though?
I'm so confused.
Straight path is on the lake?
Is this the lake?
Alright I'm grabbing my horse.
Horse!
We go straight horse!
Surely this is the right path right?
Okay.
There's so many jellyfish.
If we're time for horseback battle.
Okay there's a dragon here.
Okay.
There's a dragon here somewhere.
So many ghost animals.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I knew you existed.
Wait can I kill him?
Is this possible?
How strong are you?
Okay now he's flying.
Alright.
How strong are you?
Okay little...
Okay you whore!
Get down from here!
How the fuck am I supposed to do anything?
Alright.
Now I can fight you right?
Okay now...
Fuck this.
I'm not even gonna...
I'm not even giving you the stats.
I'm not even gonna get off my horse.
Okay I'm getting off my horse.
I'm getting off my horse.
I'm...
Never mind.
Never fucking...
Oh my god.
I... oh please, for the love of god.
I don't even know where my jellyfish is.
Is that the aurora aliboros?
Please, just let me get closer to you.
If you fly up, the moment I get to your feet, I swear to god, if you fly up, the moment I'm here.
I... oh my god, I just got here!
Oh my... hey, you did say... you said told her to come down, you did...
Not like that!
Oh my poor jellyfish.
My poor fucking jellyfish.
Okay, I'm dead.
There's no way I live through this.
This is actually so bullshit.
I... I hate him.
I hate him so much.
I hate you.
I hate... I HATE YOU!
I'll just keep shaking your legs.
This is all I can do.
All I can do is just shake his legs.
That's literally it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there he goes again!
There he goes again!
Alright.
Here I go again too!
Oh my god, you're such a little bitch!
Oh, there he goes!
Alright, fly up!
Just fly!
Oh, dad!
Yeah, fuck you too!
No!
Please, I just...
Please, just let me fucking stab your stupid ass legs!
That's all I want.
I hate the dragons so much.
Cause like...
They're so dumb.
They're actually so dumb.
They're so...
Goddamn stupid.
They're so stupid.
Oh my... How?
How?
Where did he go?
Where...
He...
Just let...
Oh my...
You know what?
I'll wait for the poison to kill you!
Wait.
If I can stab him and...
I'll just wait for the...
Poison to kill you!
Wait.
What?
What do you mean?
The poison ran out!
Of fucking course!
The poison ran out the moment I said that.
Cause fuck me, am I right?
It turned to be later.
It ran out the moment I said that.
It's alright.
I don't think he knows I'm here.
I will very slowly...
Okay, it knew.
It actually knew.
How did you know I was crouch walking?
He knew.
It smelled me.
He could smell my...
Where am I?
Oh yeah, it's the lake.
Alright, time to get my stupid runes.
That's it.
I'm just gonna fight him.
Yeah, I'm gonna fight him on my horse.
Fuck this shit.
You smelled my...
Alright, time to grab my runes.
Alright, there he comes again.
There he is.
Okay, you go do your thing real quick.
I'm gonna grab my runes.
I swear to God, where are you?
Where the fuck are you?
I swear to God, where the fuck are you?
Get out of here.
Get your ass out.
Get your...
Get your ass out of here.
Get out of here.
Get- get!
- get outta here.
I will fight you on the horse.
That's the last thing I do.
Get up.
Fucking got your toes.
Got your stupid ass toes.
All right.
You win this hack.
If just cuz you got my horse doesn't... Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
I didn't realize...
I didn't realize he would need me to fucking pay him.
To summon him again.
Where is he?
Oh fuck!
That's on me.
I was like, where is he gonna drop this sand?
Ha ha.
That's... Oh my!
That's also on me.
This guy is actually so annoying.
Oh my god.
No wonder everyone tried to kill all these dragons here.
No wonder.
It was honestly worth it.
These dragons do not deserve to be alive.
Wait!
My jellyfish is dead?
How did she die so fast?
I can't.
I can't use the horse.
I need to use a flask to use the horse.
I walked out of that summoning range.
I didn't even notice that.
I didn't even notice I walked out of the summoning range.
Oh my god.
You guys are praised.
You guys are praised when I was about to heal.
I...
Oopsie daisy.
Oh, I know.
I knew!
I knew he was gonna do it too!
I knew he was gonna do it!
I knew he was gonna do it as well!
I can feel it.
That's on me.
Okay.
I feel like... guys, I have a feeling that I might not succeed in this fight.
I don't know.
I don't know why, but I...
There's... there's a deep suspicion that he might... he might win.
Okay.
Like, it's very... his movement is predictable, but...
I get greedy.
So, like that.
Like that.
I knew he was gonna do that, but I was like, I got one more shot at me.
Truly, right?
Like right now.
Like, yeah, I knew it.
I knew it.
It's so telegraphed.
VTuber, why are you so greedy?
I can't help it!
It's just there!
Are you serious?
Guys, can I get a message of praise, please?
Please, just a little bit?
Nevermind.
I know you won't give me.
Are you serious?
I can't run that!
Oh my god.
Fuck this, I'm leaving.
You go stay in the...
I can't!
I don't have a flask!
For the horse!
He killed him!
That's it, I leave.
Fuck you!
I don't need to kill you.
I'll be back.
I'm allowed to leave.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll come back.
Guys, don't worry.
I'll come back, guys.
And then she never came back.
Razor Doki bravely running away.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll come back.
And she never did come back.
I'm not a coward!
I'm pausing the fight!
I'm just...
I'm taking a strategic pause.
That's different.
It's just a strategic pause.
Nice.
We actually needed that.
Can we upgrade any of our...
Last yet?
Yes, we can.
Aw, thank god.
Alright.
Don't worry.
We'll be back.
We'll be back, guys.
Do not worry.
Alright.
We'll go here.
Hey, where do we go?
Guess we go straight?
Yeah.
Oh, fuck this dog.
Oh my god!
Please!
Oh!
Shit!
I didn't even see...
Okay, fuck this guy.
I'm gonna...
Jesus, why are they so fast?
Oh, follow the path next to the church?
There's a path next to the church?
Hey, where is that?
I didn't see that.
Is that?
I don't see no path.
Okay, I'm gonna grab stuff again.
The path next to the church?
Seek up?
Can we up here?
Oh, this?
What's up here?
Oh, free items!
He's so lonely.
A nice smithing stone.
Okay.
Alright, we'll run past the dogs.
Come on, horse.
We're gonna do a gamer move.
And she waddled away, waddle, waddle.
She bravely waddled away.
Guys.
So brave.
Oh my god.
The bravest person of our generation.
Okay, I really have to do this.
Weeeee.
Alright.
Oh, it's this.
What is this?
Y'all enter it.
Where am I?
What the fuck?
Who are you?
Wait.
You're probably the round tape.
I thought we're friends.
Oh my god.
We're not friends.
What is that?
What is that move?
Oh my...
Jesus.
What the fuck?
He two hits me.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I...
I understand.
That's my code.
Um, hello?
Are you guys not on Team Doki?
Right now?
Okay.
I understand.
Alright.
Okay.
Just gotta interrupt.
No!
Fuck!
I didn't interrupt it.
Someone quick appraise...
appraise him.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
He dodges?
That should be cheating.
Oh my god.
And he uses magic.
What is that?
What is he...
Oh my god.
He sends out like a fucking...
He calls out the Thor.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
I got greedy.
Oh my god.
He heals.
I forgot.
He's just like me.
I forgot he's me.
He's a regular man.
So he's allowed to heal.
Oh my god.
I was like...
I almost got you now.
And I forgot he's just...
A regular man.
So he's allowed to heal.
Oh my god.
I'm not doing okay right now.
Okay.
He's so fast!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I lock in.
I'm gonna lock in.
Yeah, he anti-aired me.
Oh my god, this guy is actually the main character?
Are you fucking serious?
You mean this game isn't even about me?
It's about this guy?
He gets everything.
Also, no, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not fair.
What do you mean this game was about him?
Oh my god.
Okay, I just want...
U-turns around?
What the fuck?
That's
a U-turn.
That's if he did a fucking U-turn.
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll figure this out.
We can figure this out, guys.
We can figure this out together.
That's cheering me on.
He knows I can do it.
Or he's hungry.
It's one or the other.
I can't tell.
Alright.
Yeah, he might be the main character.
But I have fans.
Okay.
That's right.
Cheer me on, dragoons.
Cheer me on.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh.
We both had the same idea.
What?
Okay.
He's like, fed?
No, we don't.
Okay.
Maybe we both did not have the same idea.
Maybe not.
Maybe he's right.
Maybe we did not have the same idea, guys.
I don't know.
I thought...
I thought we'd be cool.
We'd be cool, you know?
Oh, God.
I got greedy again.
I got greedy.
Oh, my God.
You fucking healed.
Okay.
Lock in.
I'm locking in.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
He's backing out because he's scared.
Oh, fuck.
Never mind.
He's not scared.
He's clearly not scared, guys.
Never mind.
Silly me for thinking he was scared.
He's literally the main character.
Why would he be scared?
No more.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
He has another one.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, my God.
I can't be greedy.
Don't fucking hell, you bitch.
That's right.
That's your last one.
Yes.
That's right.
I'm the main character now.
I will be on the cover of that magazine.
That's right.
I'll become you.
Then I'll be on the cover.
It's my turn to be on the cover of Elden Ring.
That's right.
I'm you now.
Is that him?
Oh, wait.
His helmet is weaker.
What the fuck?
Why the fuck would I ever want to be him?
Well, his armor is weaker.
Well, his armor is dog shit.
What?
My Oshii's on the cover now.
Bro, your armor isn't even fucking worth it.
What the fuck?
Okay.
It is.
No, it's not.
But it's better because it's lighter.
Not the point.
Alright.
Let's see.
Is it actually better?
Pierce.
Strike.
Slash.
Aren't I Slash though?
I'm Slash.
That dog disagrees.
Oh my god.
Everything is worse.
Wait.
Am I...
Oh!
It's negation.
I'm stupid.
Okay.
This one is...
I'll admit that this one...
I'll take your shoes.
I'll only take your shoes.
And that's it.
A robustness.
Immunity.
What?
I'm not gonna have bust size anymore?
Okay.
Alright.
I'll take your shoes.
And your shirt.
Not the shirt.
Wait.
Is this light roll?
Or a heavy roll?
I can't tell.
Guys.
Jordans.
That's right.
They're my shoes now.
Okay.
We gotta...
Actually.
Let's head back to...
Hmm.
Is there a...
There's no light roll, right?
It's just medium and heavy.
Is there any grace near me?
Yeah?
Okay.
Where is the grace that's nearby?
Oh, there is light roll.
Okay.
Stick to the right?
Cause like...
I don't wanna go all the way back.
South-West.
Right here?
I assume it's like somewhere here.
Oh, near the camp.
Okay.
The camp's here.
I almost said South-West.
I was...
Oh!
That's South-West.
The camp's here.
Oh, yeah.
It's near here.
It's on the other side of this camp.
The...
Okay.
I'll go up top.
Should be fine.
I can just run past it all.
Is it here?
Guardian's Garrison?
Oh, my God.
There's a dog here.
I passed it.
Oh, I passed it.
I passed it somewhere.
And I don't know where.
And...
Oh, there's a lot of people around me.
Hello?
Whoa!
Okay.
Goodbye.
Oh, my God.
It was right here.
I love.
Oh, my God.
She missed.
Ha, you missed, idiot.
There we go.
We're okay.
Okay, skilled.
Gotta take this off.
We're almost there.
The flame of ruin lies just ahead.
I'm glad it was you.
I traveled.
Oh, look.
She said me.
Not...
Not anyone else.
Thank you.
Torrent.
Please continue to ask your aid.
Till the end.
Excuse me.
Um...
Horse barely did as much as I did.
By the way.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
Without protection.
Oh, my God.
Without...
Without protection.
Skin on skin contact, guys.
All right.
What was it?
Oh, it was Arcana 20.
Right?
Okay.
All right.
Oh.
I got the contact that I wanted.
All right.
Nice.
I got everything I need.
I'm gonna fuck these ditties.
We gotta figure out how to get over here.
How do we get over there?
The fuck?
We just go up?
No, the vine!
Follow the paths?
Like here?
Check where this goes.
I'm a little confused.
Oh, there's a bridge here.
Oh, nice.
Never mind.
Not confused anymore.
What's that castle for?
What was that castle for, anyway?
Oh, it's just loot?
Oh, okay.
Oh, nice.
We finally have a map, too.
Hey, map!
Oh, look at all these dead giants.
Oh, what happened to them?
What happened to these guys?
Why didn't they just...
Oh, did they got killed by the tree virus?
Is that it?
What?
Yeah, like, what was it called?
The...
Tree virus thing?
Death root?
Are they fighting each other?
Wait, is this a war?
Birds versus...
Death flight.
Wait, do I get free solos?
I'm gonna watch to get free runes.
They're just jamming.
Tree virus.
Oh, no.
They got him.
Holy shit, that's a...
Oh, my God.
Wait, I...
No, no.
I can't bring him over?
Eh.
Invaded.
Oh, there he is.
Wait, why is he doing here?
Wait, who the fu...
How did you get in here?
What the fu...
Why are you in my fucking...
Okay.
Oh, my God.
He...
He and I are the same.
He's copying my move.
What?
He can roll through my move?
Oh, my God.
He's actually better than me.
He's so much better.
He's actually...
He's literally...
He's like the sensei.
He's actually the sensei right now.
Oh,
my God.
He's such a bitch.
I'll take your armor, too.
Are you serious?
All he does is roll.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
That's all he does!
That's all we both do!
No!
We just roll!
Oh, wait.
All you do is roll, too, Doki.
What do you mean?
Does it so much better than me!
How is he doing to so much better than me?
Holy shit, that's so scary.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Are you serious?
At least he doesn't drink potions.
Thank fucking God.
Fuck this guy.
Fuck.
You roll with fear.
He rolls with purpose.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna be you, too.
Wait.
Wait, he has a new katana.
Wait, which katana's better?
Wait, which one's better?
Do I...
Do I get rid of this katana?
Or the serpent bone katana?
What do I get rid of?
Begone serpent?
Okay.
Get rid of serpent.
Alright.
Wait, what do I need?
I need more arcane.
Oh, my God.
Why the fuck, guys?
Why didn't you...
Why didn't you warn me?
Oh, put that on your left hand?
Okay.
Okay, so...
Oh, no.
Okay, put this on my right.
Okay.
Put this here.
And then...
Yeah, okay.
We've been working.
Why did you keep making me, dude?
Why did you try to convince me to do faith?
Oh.
No.
Is that not...
Do I put this on this hand or this hand?
Do I put rivers of blood on my right hand or left hand?
Guys.
Which one?
We were working on it in the beginning.
In the river of blood, my beloved.
Right, okay.
So I did get it right.
Alright, let's upgrade our sword, though.
Let's do that real quick.
Oh, I can get flask, too.
Okay.
Yes.
Alright, now we're plus seven.
Alright.
I know there's an easier way to do this, but...
I'm old-fashioned right now.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's upgrade this.
I could foc...
Actually, let's focus on getting...
Uh...
Let's actually...
Let's focus on leveling up first.
Actually...
Okay.
How much do I need to level up?
Uh...
How much do I need?
Two?
Okay.
What's a good place to farm?
What do I farm?
That...
Where I won't die.
Wait.
Oh, yeah.
Let's eat the bossels.
Who do you want to eat?
Om-yum-yum.
It's time.
Okay.
I have one extra here.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
I have this.
Alright.
It's time.
We gotta eat one of them.
We gotta eat one of the bosses.
It's om-yum-yum time.
Wait.
How many do I get?
Eat the rich.
Do I eat the deer?
It's time.
I've always...
I want to eat venison today.
Om-yum-yum.
Um-yum-yum-yum.
It's time!
Wait.
Is this how I use remembrance?
Om-yum-yum-yum.
Do it for my blood sword.
Is that how you do it?
Yeah!
Om-yum-yum-yum-yum-yum-yum.
Om-yum-yum.
Hahaha.
That's right.
Alright.
Let's get our cane in.
Okay, we just need 20k more.
I can farm that.
No, let's farm that, actually.
Uh... Let's farm that in that dungeon.
You know that dungeon where it takes, like, one hit?
It, like, gives us 800 per... Uh... No, I can farm that.
I can... I just do, like, 800 per...
Where's that dungeon again?
The little guys?
It's 800 souls per kill.
So I can just farm that.
Uh... Yeah, but then the giants?
I'm scared of dying to them.
So, like, I'd rather just farm the little, like, the little guys.
Where was that dungeon again?
Is it this one?
Freezing?
No.
Ancient snow ruins?
Which one was it?
Is it this one, right?
This one.
No.
That's where we have to go.
God damn it.
I'm, like... No, that's where all the giants are.
And I don't want to deal with those giants.
This one?
This one.
No.
This one?
This one.
It's fine.
I mean, it's, like... I just killed, like, it's, like, I... Three of them... No.
No.
Not this one.
God damn it.
Where the fuck is that dungeon?
Oh, there you go.
I found it.
It's the catacombs right here.
Yeah.
It's this one.
Oh, it's more close.
It's 800 per tiny guy.
So, I can just kill the tiny men.
Get over here.
I'm hungry.
Um, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Oh, my God.
It took so long to kill.
It takes so long to kill, though.
I forgot that because, um, my sword is not upgraded at all.
Holy shit.
Yeah, this guy's taking stones.
Oh, my God.
They're fucking me up.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I remember now.
Okay, I need to get my other sword in.
So I can farm these guys, at least.
Yeah, I can at least farm them easily.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna die there.
I'm gonna die the babies.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh, remember when I said all these guys would be so easy to farm?
I'm sure.
Okay.
These guys are fucking me up, though.
All right.
Let me swap swords real quick.
I got a swap sword so I can upgrade my arcade and then we can talk.
We can talk.
Okay.
We'll...
Just for now.
Just for now, guys.
So we can grab our upgrades real quick.
Just...
I could just...
Yeah.
Okay.
There we go.
No.
They're a lot easier.
They're definitely a lot easier.
Okay.
Eh, no.
We can two-hand this.
There you go.
All right.
Let's see.
How much do we need?
41k, right?
Don't worry.
We'll be back.
How much do we need?
41?
Okay.
This is gonna take a bit, but it'll be worth it, guys.
It'll be worth it.
Trust me.
This is like the safest farm stuff.
Like, this is so safe.
I feel so safe in here.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I gotta say that, and then...
It'll be so worth it, guys.
See, look at that.
We're at 28k already.
They're like 3k for a fight.
Yeah, I got all...
Um...
All my...
The golden runes.
I already used it all up.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, shit.
I forgot about the sword upgrades.
Fuck.
I forgot about that, too.
Guys, how much do we need for the sword upgrades?
Yes.
I forgot about the other important thing.
Are you serious?
Oh, my God.
Why are you guys...
Why are BNPing pussies right now?
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
You guys don't really matter.
Are you serious, bro?
Are you serious?
Get out of here.
Get...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I was gonna say.
If he gets that bleed, I'm dead.
20k for...
Okay.
That's just gonna...
I have to sell...
Yeah, I gotta sell stuff.
I'll sell stuff after I get the upgrade shit here.
Yeah.
Get out of here.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I got this...
That's...
I got it in my groove.
What?
Oh, my God.
He's, like, wanting to be fed.
He wanted to be...
He wanted to be fed, like, an hour early.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
As long as I grab this.
Things are okay.
He's trying to cheese the system.
Because it's, like, 3...
It's, like, 3.58.
So, he's trying to cheese the system.
He's, like, You don't feed me.
You don't win game.
No focus.
No feed.
He keeps running the same scam.
Thinking it'll work.
Alright.
We're almost there, guys.
We're almost there.
Over here.
I'll keep farming you over and over.
It's a time loop.
It's a loop.
This loop never ends.
It ends.
That's fucking right.
Die!
Alright.
Two more times.
We're looping.
We're still looping.
We keep looping.
All right.
Two more.
Oh, wait.
Shit.
I forgot to...
Press it again.
Whoops.
There you go.
Oh, I can't even remember to spam this.
All right.
Bro, I know you're here.
Like, we've been through this already.
This is like the Aether 9th loop.
Give me...
Give me your lunch money.
All right.
One last loop.
Here we go.
The groundhog fire.
All right.
Get out of here!
That's right.
Stay looping!
Okay.
That.
Dead.
Oh, and more stones for me.
Let's go.
All right.
Nice.
That should be enough for the level up.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It was 42.
That's fine.
I'll...
One more for the ride.
One more...
One more for the ride, I guess.
There you go.
Okay.
And then...
Last guy here.
That's fine.
I don't give you a little freebie yet.
Because you deserve it.
All right.
Now we...
We good to go.
All right.
Up top.
It was up time.
Yeah!
All right.
Now...
Now we go home.
We go home.
And we're gonna sell...
Some stuff.
We're gonna...
We're gonna sell our things.
And sell my things to her.
All right.
Wait.
Purchase?
How do I sell?
Wait.
You don't...
Oh.
Wait.
He doesn't...
She doesn't take my things.
Wait.
Who do I talk to?
Who takes my items?
Oh.
The smith guy?
I sell at the blacksmith.
Okay.
All right.
Take my stuff.
Sell.
Okay.
What do I sell, guys?
What do I not need?
I have so many things that I don't know what I not need.
Majority of my items?
What are they, though?
I have so much meat on me.
Holy shit.
What can I sell?
Oh, my God.
Sell a remembrance?
Why don't I just use a remembrance?
Where's my...
Yeah, my items don't really...
Oh, I can sell these guys.
Wait.
I'll just sell these guys.
What do you think I don't?
I'll just sell my duplicates, too.
All right.
That's it.
Fuck it.
It's time to go back to farm.
I can't be bothered.
We go back.
Did you miss me, little guys?
I'm here.
I'm here to...
I'm here to beat you up again.
Groundhog Day.
It's not over yet.
No.
I'm going to hoard my remembrance.
Maybe I'll need it.
You don't know that.
Remember me?
It's Groundhog Day again.
It's never ended.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
That was close.
Because they actually try to fight back.
They try to...
They try to fight back.
Holy shit.
I'm saving it for Elder Ring, too.
Please.
Because what if these items are very important for...
Okay.
Bye.
Oh, my God.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
How did they, like, get better?
She's right.
You don't know that.
What if...
What if it happens?
Okay.
And what if I need...
What if I need it for Elden Ring 3?
You don't know that, guys.
I might need it for Elden Ring 3, guys.
There you go.
Nice.
All right.
Three more times.
Yeah.
It unlocks a secret boss fight in Elden Ring 4.
If I keep it all...
I'll be able to...
And then we'll be laughing now.
Everyone will be like, Oh, no.
I used my bosses.
Because I thought I wouldn't need them.
And then they made it so you'll unlock the secret boss in Elden Ring 4.
And then I'll be the one laughing.
Because I hoarded it all for this special occasion.
You never punish the hoarders.
Nice.
All right.
The strats.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's...
We're almost there, guys.
We're almost there.
We're gonna make it.
I need 20k, right?
All right.
Okay.
Wait.
His eye's glowing.
That means he'll give me more.
Right?
Get over here.
How much did he give me?
I told you it was worth it.
Oh, my...
Okay.
Look at that.
Bonus souls.
God rewarded me for my efforts.
He...
Because I believed.
I believed.
And he rewarded me.
The gods above in Elden Ring.
I was like, you know what's up.
I did it.
The devs knew.
The devs were like, live patch it right now.
And give Doki all those runes.
And she deserves it.
She's trying to save up for the secret DLC...
The secret boss that we're planning on adding...
Uh...
In Elden Ring 4.
The devs heard me.
And live patched it in.
Okay.
This is very off topic.
But this video...
Like, popped...
Like...
This video I watched two days ago popped up in my head.
And it's like...
Of XQC...
Watching Dora the Explorer.
And Dora was like...
What's our horse's favorite...
Favorite food?
And XQC's like...
Apple!
Oh my god.
Yeah, that showed up in my head.
And then...
And then Dora's like...
It's Apple!
And it's like...
I knew it.
He's like...
Congratulating himself.
Truly the streamer of our time.
Dude, I feel like that'd be me though.
Oh shit.
Oh, what the fuck is that?
Okay.
Alright.
That should be enough.
Sounds like...
Yeah, I just like...
That sounds like something I would do.
Yeah.
Is that the rare helmet?
Yeah, but that's shit.
That mask actually has a low drop rate.
Oh, like it's hard?
Okay, but what does it do?
Oh!
Oh, 8.1 though.
Yeah, that doubles.
That's double.
Um...
Okay, I should have enough now.
How many...
Okay, let's check how many I need.
Yeah, like it's hard to get.
Like...
Okay, I need...
Oh wait.
I have this.
Yeah, I have...
Okay, I have enough.
I have enough.
Okay, I need smithing stone 7.
Okay, sombra smithing stone 7.
Okay.
Can you buy that or no?
Oh, I can't.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why did you guys make me farm 20k?
I spent...
I spent 20k.
I spent 3k.
Yeah.
Spent 3k!
I...
Can you use the bathroom?
All right.
How am I supposed to find...
Sombra smithing stone 7.
We're fine.
Where's the closest one?
Probably on a mine?
Bell bearings?
Where do I go for that?
Oh my god.
Why can't I move my...
It's so weird.
Okay, there you go.
The castle in the north?
The castle?
Oh.
The zamar ruins.
The fuck is that?
Oh, I have a bell bearing offer?
Oh, I...
Okay, I'll give that to...
I don't think that...
That's like the item I need though.
Pretty sure.
God, I got a lot...
Like disoriented there.
I'm not here.
Not here.
I do have one.
What does it give me though?
Not the thing I fucking need it.
I do need this though.
But...
I won't buy it yet.
Seven in Volcano Manor?
Do I have?
Okay, grace by a lift?
Where the fuck is that?
There's so many lifts, guys.
Guys, there's so many lifts.
You guys gotta be much more specific which lift it is.
Like...
True.
So it's like...
The grace by the lift.
I'm like...
What do you...
There's so many.
There's so many lifts around me.
Like...
Start...
Where the NPC is?
This one?
Wait, no.
This...
Which one is it?
This one?
Okay, give me the name of the grace, guys.
Guys, the name of the grace.
That would be easier.
This one, the Xamarin ruins?
Okay.
Now we're here.
Where do we go?
Now where do we go?
West...
This way?
South?
Oh, to the ruins.
Okay.
What does my right thing do?
Okay, does that.
Okay.
Okay, and then where is...
Past the ruins.
Okay, if it's past the ruins, I'm just gonna ride this.
Okay, there's a lady here.
To the left.
I think she sees me.
I think she saw me.
I can't see anything here.
It's just...
Oh!
Fucking hell!
I'm a stupid bird.
Oh, it's on the right side.
Okay.
Check the trees.
Oh my God, I swear to God.
I'm gonna fucking look up a picture.
I'm gonna Google the picture.
I swear to God.
Okay, this way.
In the ruins?
But we already did the ruins.
We already went through that hole.
No, we went through that hole already.
And got the item.
Didn't we get the item already down there?
It's on a fucking tree?
Yeah, we went through that.
We went through that.
And got an item in there.
Oh my God.
We already got that.
We got that already.
Alright, I'm Googling.
That's it.
You've lost your privileges, chat.
I'm Googling.
You've lost your privileges.
It's Google time.
Probably for the best.
No!
Privilege has been revoked.
It's time to Google.
Alright.
Elden Ring.
Sombra.
Stone.
Level 7.
Alright.
Where can I find this shit?
From here.
The fucking mouth.
Okay.
All 7.
All Sombra.
Smithing Stones.
What's good, y'all?
That play.
Okay.
The first air is like...
What's...
What's good, y'all?
It's your boy, Husky Mania.
Okay.
Wait.
Actually, you guys should listen to this intro.
What's good, y'all?
It's your boy, the Husky Mania.
Back in the building with another informal Elden Ring video for y'all.
Chat.
This is who I replaced you with.
Classic.
Deserved.
I'm my boy, Husky.
How could you?
Okay, did we get... I don't even know we got the one in Volcano Manor.
Let's check.
It is so much cooler than us.
I did not say that.
I trusted with my life.
Alright.
Okay.
He's gonna take me through this way.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's see.
I need to figure out where the fuck is he going.
Okay.
So... He went... Alright.
He went... This way?
This way?
He went this way and then... Where the fuck is he going?
Oh my god.
He baited me.
He fucking baited me.
And then he did this.
This guy did this.
He was like... Alright.
We're gonna go down there and then we're gonna go... Bitch.
Okay.
Alright.
Did I unlock the door?
Guys, I did not unlock the door.
How the fuck do I... How do you unlock this door?
He was like... You've been there.
You must have unlocked this door already.
Guys, we didn't unlock this door.
Wait a minute.
It's unlocked.
Can we... Can we... Okay.
Okay.
Alright.
So... Apparently... Is it... Through here?
We have this door.
We have... Does this count?
We do have this door.
I have to go that long way?
Not to... Not to look up... How to unlock this door.
How... Wrong one.
Oh my god.
Now I have to...
Unlock the... How to look up a video.
On how to unlock... That door.
I have a grace there.
Thank fucking god.
Which is it?
Guys.
Which is the grace for this?
For the...
The chain continues.
Yeah.
TP to the temple.
And then follow the path.
The temple?
Yes.
What?
Chat's thrown out for... She replaced you.
And where do we go?
Where's the path?
What?
Look.
Okay.
You guys have a chance to redeem yourself.
Right here.
This is your... Okay.
Bye.
Guys.
You have a chance to redeem yourself.
Take me to the door.
Unlock.
And then we'll... We'll talk.
And we'll talk, guys.
We'll talk, guys.
Alright.
And then you'll get your privileges again.
Okay.
Now where do I go?
It's... West?
Maybe makes sense.
I don't wanna... Maybe ask your boy, Husky.
Husky.
Yeah.
Ask your new best friend, Doki.
Ask Husky.
Guys.
It was just a joke.
Your boy, Husky, could never replace you.
I swear.
Yeah.
Ask...
Guys.
I was joking, guys.
I would never replace you with your boy, Husky.
I would never do such a thing.
Too late.
Guys.
It was just a hee-hee-ha-ha moment, guys.
We're still...
We're still here together.
Guys.
We're all...
We're all friends here.
I don't put...
Guys.
Come on.
You know.
You wanna tell me what to do?
I'm just a dumb VTuber.
Who is so lost.
Oh.
Where do I go?
I'm such a sleepy VTuber.
I don't know what to do.
Oh.
If only I have a backseater that can tell me where to go.
If only...
Oh, I'm so silly and stupid.
If only I have a backseater that knows exactly where to go.
I'm glad you are lost.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If only...
Indy...
...
I'm tired of this manipulation.
I'm so dumb.
I don't know where to go.
Oh, I'm so dumb.
Fine!
I'll look up a YouTube cat for my boy Husky!
Alright, Husky!
Where do I fucking lock this sewer?
What?
Where the fuck do I go?
What the?
Where is this?
Where is he?
Open?
What?
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Oh my god, you guys are... you guys fucked with me.
You guys actually... oh my god.
Oh my god.
It was...
Oh.
My.
God.
Oh my god.
It was out here.
It was...
It was out here all along.
Oh my god.
Straight.
Good.
What?
Okay, we'll figure this out.
We'll figure this out.
We gotta figure out...
How to...
Get started in the ass, Husky.
At chat!
How...
How do I get...
Chat.
Come on, chat.
Oh my god.
Chat, come on.
We're homies, right?
We're... we're homies.
We're...
We're like...
BFFs, guys.
Oh, they patched it?
Well, you should have played it when...
When it was so possible.
Let's...
I'll figure this out.
Okay.
I'll...
I'll give you a shout out.
I'll give you a...
I will acknowledge you.
Okay.
Maybe it's here?
Here?
And then...
Oh, wait.
Maybe it's here.
And then...
Um...
No.
Oh, I don't know.
Maybe ask your boy...
Okay.
Not here.
And then...
I'll go this way.
And then I'll go...
Go this way.
And...
That's it.
That's right.
My boy Husky know what's up.
My boy Husky.
Me and my...
Husky...
Boy.
Husky goon boy.
You know what's up.
That's right.
I'll figure this out.
Right here.
Remember this guy?
When I got rare drop after one try?
Yeah.
That's fucking right.
I will pay you no more.
I've been betrayed far too many times.
I will no longer fall for your womanly will.
I'm the Mexicans.
Thank you.
We're the super chat.
Come on, bro.
Come on.
Help a bro out.
Well, you guys really...
Really...
We're out, bro.
Come on.
Don't you wanna help a homie out?
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay.
I'm here now.
Where am I?
I don't have enough.
I don't know.
Okay.
Oh, it's here.
Haha.
I knew it.
Help me if he betrays us.
Wait.
Where am I?
Oh, I don't have enough.
Wait.
I don't have the keys.
Was this actually the way?
Hahaha.
It's not...
What was that?
I don't even...
I don't even have the key for it.
Now, guys.
Now, Google how to get keys.
I can buy...
I...
I can buy more keys.
I am...
I...
I know he has keys.
I know he has...
Let me just...
Hahaha.
I can buy a key here.
I know she has a key.
I...
Okay.
Now, we get a key here.
Wait.
There's no key.
Oh my...
Wait, there is.
I know I...
I knew I had an extra key.
There's so many Sombra 7s.
It's too late.
I'm committed to...
I'm committed now.
Wait, wait.
Hahaha.
Because at least...
My boy Huskies got me.
Hahaha.
Thank you for the super...
No, I already put one in it.
I...
That guy already has one of my keys.
I already...
I remember I put one key on him.
Okay.
It's fine.
We've committed to this.
I've made my bed.
Didn't I not put one in?
Chat, don't help.
It's too late.
I'm...
Okay.
Just in case.
I don't trust any of you anymore.
I...
Hahaha.
Okay.
Alright.
We have enough money for it.
Your boy Husky can appraise the messages too.
Guys.
Come on.
God.
Your homie made one mistake.
Guys.
Your...
Your boy made one mistake.
Guys.
Come on.
You gotta...
Hang out again.
Just like old times.
Just like...
Your boy.
You know...
You know when they like...
When your boy...
You know like when...
One of your homies...
Um...
Chose a girl over the boys.
And then like...
They break up.
And they're like...
Guys.
I made a mistake.
Like I was just...
You know...
I...
I made a mistake.
Guys.
Like we're...
We're over.
I should never have chosen...
Her over.
You.
Guys.
Look at me.
I'm...
I'm back.
They are...
Dead to me.
We never forget.
Bro.
Your boy just...
Made a little oopsie.
And was like...
You know...
Look like...
It's over.
She was nothing...
Between you and the boys.
Between us and the boys.
Guys.
Oh my god.
What the hell...
Google talking...
What...
What do you mean...
Mexicon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What do you mean?
It was one...
Teensy toddy mistake.
But it's okay now.
We're...
We're okay now.
Right boys?
Where am I?
Oh.
This is an accident.
Wait.
Take me back up.
Not...
Food time!
He still wants food.
Alright.
We go this way.
Okay.
I found the shortcut.
I forgot about...
Okay.
Well now...
Look at that.
See?
Everything is okay now.
Everything is okay.
Okay.
And then...
We go...
It's okay.
We can deal...
Why did you betray them?
He's like...
I'll never betray them!
Oh my god.
He got closer.
He...
He feels our pain!
We can't do that...
We can't do that.
Okay.
Alright.
See guys?
Good thing I bought too.
It was my own decision for that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ, I don't like this parkour.
I do not like this parkour area.
I... I don't like this.
Alright, I'm gonna feed him early.
I'm gonna be right back.
I'm gonna feed him.
He won.
Okay.
I'm back.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Drag wounds, look upon this pathetic streamer.
Crawling back for forgiveness from us.
She does not earn us even status.
Guys, come on.
It's a little oopsie between bros.
Come on.
I've seen the error of my ways.
I... Husky meant nothing to me, guys.
Husky meant nothing.
That guy would never replace the bros.
I would always take my... My backseeding from my dragoons who have never led me astray.
All right, here I go.
Back at it again.
Fool me, what?
Oh, I'm... Oh my god.
He's gonna fuck me.
Oh my god.
Please.
No more false prophet.
Praise that.
Holy shit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
I actually don't know where the elevator shortcut is.
Take the elevator.
I'm like, I don't even know where that is.
I'll just go the way that I've been going on.
Oh, left from the grace for the shortcut.
See?
I knew you guys would forgive me.
I knew it all can be forgiven, guys.
I knew it.
Wait, where is my grace?
Is it all the way down there?
Oh no, it's just...
No!
Okay.
All right.
Now that I've unlocked the shortcut, things will be easier.
Things will be easier now that I've unlocked the shortcut.
I have the shortcut.
It's fine.
It is fine.
I...
It's okay.
Mexicot, thank you for the...
Thank you, pandai.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat, Mexicot.
We're going to tell Mint about the inju...
What?
Injustice!
It was a little oopsie.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
All is forgiven.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He's just playing.
He's just doing flame on.
All right.
Just go up here.
Guys, I've seen the error of my ways.
I will never use a YouTube guide over your amazing, lovely directions and back seating.
You guys have never led me astray.
Oh my god.
How could I ever just use a YouTube guide when I have you guys?
That's right.
I...
Are you serious?
What the fuck is hitting me?
Are you...
Oh my god.
Shit, that was close.
Where do I go from here?
Excuse me?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, lock the door.
It's not our fault you suck at following directions.
All right.
Is this door?
Oh, it's this door.
Oh my god.
I finally...
I finally opened the door.
I finally did it.
Get out of here.
You followed enough.
All right.
We just run.
We finally made it.
I want this.
Oh my god.
There's so many of them.
They're just all on the body.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
Nomming.
They're all just nomming at me.
Oh my god.
I forgot what the guide said after this.
They're just...
Where do I go?
Oh my god.
It's right here.
I didn't see that door.
Oh my god.
He's right...
They're right behind us.
Oh fuck!
I got it.
Sombra 7.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything is fine.
All right.
It's done.
It's finally done.
Oh my god.
Our fucking filler episode is over.
All right.
Filler episode.
Kevin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Turkey.
You're flicking me a migraine affectionately.
Thank you for the super chat.
Kevin.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
We did it.
After all that.
I don't have money.
I don't have...
God I...
Okay.
It's fine.
It's...
No, it's fine.
Back at the ground...
It's Groundhog Day.
Yeah.
It's fine.
We're back for Groundhog Day.
It's okay.
All right.
We got this.
I want to try out the...
Let's see.
All right.
If I upgrade this even more, it's gonna be crazy.
Okay.
That's okay.
We'll do one more here too.
There's so many better ways to get runes.
Well, we're here now.
We...
We all suffer together here.
We shall do it as inefficiently as possible.
We all deserve this.
What is the red stuff anyway?
Is that like...
From my bleed?
Yeah, I know.
We all know what I'm doing.
We all...
We did nothing wrong.
This is a team effort.
This is a group effort, guys.
Well, I took you no matter.
Now, we can upgrade.
Oh, my God.
I...
Alright.
This...
We...
Now, where do we find...
Smithings...
Sombra's Stone 8.
Now!
Okay, guys.
This is the redemption arc right now.
Where is 8?
This is your chance to tell me where 8 is.
There was one before the Divine Carlos Tower that drops from the scarab.
And where is that?
Divine?
Sorry, I don't speak English.
Guys, where is the Divine?
Whatever.
What the fuck is that tower?
What's next to the sniper in the mountains?
Which sniper?
The one in the long-ass bridge?
This one?
This bridge?
Wait, how the fuck... This long-ass bridge right here?
Or this one?
I don't remember which bridge it was.
Is it Kaylin?
Broken Bond.
Thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you.
I'm fine since a few people asked me in DMs and I got mad again.
I rage quit vaccinating Toki because she ran to ask you, guys.
You happy now?
I trusted her to be a reasonable person.
But when she decided to watch the video, it felt like a betrayal.
Broken Bond.
Bro.
He don't mean like that to me, bro.
What?
You and the Dragoons and I are special Dragoons.
Wait.
Husky.
Husky was just a fad.
Just...
This is different.
Dragoons.
You heard him.
No!
Broken just like me.
Broken Bond truly is a broken...
Alright, Dragoons.
Come on.
Give me another chance.
And then he has to be like, How many more chances do we have to give you, Toki?
I'm running thin.
And then this is like a little...
And then we have our little soap opera.
Our little...
And the credits are rolling.
And then I grab your arms like, I'm like, Dragoons, please don't leave me.
I don't know what to do.
What about your backseating?
And then credits roll.
And then we won't know what happens.
Until the next episode.
Um...
I can't do this anymore.
It's too much.
Okay.
Divine Tower.
Where the fuck is that?
The fuck is the Divine Tower?
The church by the samurai?
Oh!
The samurai?
Where did I kill the samurai?
This guy?
Church.
Yeah?
The cinema.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Now we gotta figure out.
Where to get the eighth stone.
Alright.
Okay.
Now where do we go?
Oh, Kaleid?
The fuck?
Where the fuck is it?
Guys, I don't know where Kaleid is.
I don't even know.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
That's Kaleid.
Here's Kaleid.
Wait.
Where do we go in Kaleid then?
The big red palace?
This palace?
Oh, this palace.
Oh.
North of Kaleid.
So that we go up?
Okay, but which one?
There's...
Well...
Inner...
Anoria.
There's...
We go this way?
Yeah?
We can grab a map here too, actually.
Let's go grab a map of...
Yeah, let's just grab a map here.
Let's get rid of the one.
Wherever that shit is.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's above me, isn't it?
It's...
Wait, I was right next to it?
Oh my god.
Okay, let's go back.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's figure this out.
There is apparently...
A stone here next to me.
One teensy-weensy stone.
That's right next to me.
East.
This way.
I am next to a teensy-weensy...
Oh, that guy?
Right here?
Is it that...
That scarab?
Right up above me?
Oh, okay.
How the fuck do I shoot that down?
Alright.
Let's figure out how to get up there.
That shit's gonna take me fucking forever to shoot that.
I'm just gonna climb up.
Oh, look!
Feet!
Holy shit!
Where did they...
Oh, I have to range fight.
I have to range...
All right.
I'll grab the bow.
Grab the bow.
Let me grab the bow.
Where is my fucking...
Where is my trusty bow?
Wait, actually, where is...
Okay.
My level one bow.
Where is it?
All right.
Oh, boy.
Do I not have arrows for it?
Are you serious?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I need to craft...
There's so many things I have to do.
There we go.
Nice.
All right.
We did it.
Okay.
Look.
See, guys?
See?
Look at us.
Look at us, guys.
Our chemistry is so good, guys.
Look at us.
I told...
I never replace you guys.
Come on.
Look at how easy that was, Dragoons.
Look at that.
That's so easy.
See?
I told you Husky meant nothing.
Look at that.
You guys...
Me and you, me and you, Dragoons?
Oh, we have something going here.
You're backseating in my gameplay.
It's something special, Dragoons.
He has something special, Dragoons.
Alright.
Okay, now...
Okay, where's nine?
Where the fuck is nine?
Alright, now we need to find nine!
Okay, Kaelin, for real now.
Now we need a fucking... Oh, we don't need to get nine yet?
No more?
Divine Tower.
How do we get to the Divine Tower?
How do I get to here, to be fair?
Can't do it from here?
Not needed?
Oh!
Okay, then we're fine.
Let's leave.
Actually, I'll go upgrade my jellyfish.
Hey, what?
Six?
I'll just buy the... Um, let's just buy the... I think I can buy, like, the stuff right here.
Oh gosh, we can get rid of the bone.
Here we go.
Alright.
You have enough?
Ah, fuck.
I need 4k.
Alright, go to Kaelin from Limgrave?
Limgrave?
I don't have Limgrave.
I have no idea what you guys are talking about.
Oh, left area?
Oh, this Limgrave.
That's what you mean.
I thought this was Kaelin.
Alright, that's fine.
Now we can progress, guys.
It's okay.
We can finally progress now.
Are we supposed to go here?
What's here, anyway?
Oh, that's the Volcano Manor.
Alright.
Okay.
Now we gotta figure out where to go.
Now...
Alright, now... Now we can finally progress.
After everything we've been through.
We can finally move forward.
We did it!
We finally did it!
Look at that.
And our relationship is fixed now.
Oh my god, I almost like...
I almost went into the depths of hell.
Oh yeah.
Oh, here it is.
Oh, it's like a little chain.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, that's the boss.
Oh, I know how... I know about this boss, guys.
I've seen...
I've seen a lot of videos about this guy.
I know what to do.
Watch this.
Okay.
That's... um...
The players in the video... make it look a lot easier.
They really did make that look a lot easier.
Than what it actually was.
I thought... I thought it'd be a lot easier, okay?
They really did make it seem incredibly easy to do.
They really did look very easy in the videos.
Um...
While you really showed us.
Alright.
Okay.
This is fine.
I... I know what to do now.
I know what to do.
Okay.
This time... this time... I... I... I can do better.
I... I can do better this time.
I don't need my grace.
It's just too...
Okay.
See, guys?
I told you guys.
I know about the video!
Oh, no.
Okay.
Oh, God!
Oh,
God!
Oh, God!
Okay, that...
That wasn't supposed to happen in the video to...
That wasn't...
The video didn't warn me about that!
The video...
This video... This video didn't warn me about that.
Oh, there's a Grace nearby, thank god.
Forget the video, don't key lock it.
It's okay, I got this.
I know what to do now.
For real, this time.
Wait, where is the other Grace?
I said there's a Grace nearby.
Is it that one?
Is it actually nearby though?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it is.
Okay.
Yeah, this is...
This is actually near.
Okay.
I've seen...
I figured it out.
I've downloaded everything.
My...
I now know what to do.
I figured it out.
Okay, it's right here.
I keep forgetting where the chains are.
Alright.
We got this.
Okay.
Alright, you bait.
You go bait.
And then you poison him.
And then I'll do the actual job.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Are you seri- Tor- Tor- Tor- Tor- Tor- Tor- Tor- Tor-
That is fine.
Sometimes that happens in the video too, guys.
Sometimes...
Sometimes that happens in the video as well.
Okay.
What?
Oh my God.
Okay.
Oh no.
Oh
my God.
Thank God.
Oh my God.
No, not...
No.
Oh no!
It's okay.
Okay, that fire is just very slowly approaching me.
Okay, that was obviously a...
Okay, okay, okay.
That, I will say, might be a little bullshit.
It's okay, I'm safe like in this little cubby hole I made for myself.
I feel so safe.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
No!
I caught it!
Awww!
I caught it.
I did too many choppy chops.
I chopped too much.
I got greedy.
Too many chops.
No!
Why did I chop?
I chopped till I dropped.
Okay.
Guys, I figured it out.
Guys, I figured, guys, look at me go.
I figured it out.
Okay, maybe I should actually...
I should really get, like...
Yeah.
Wait, is it boost fire damage?
Okay.
There we go.
I feel like that might be useful.
That may or may not be very useful.
Andre, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Okay.
Child, help me.
My child.
I got this.
I need it.
Tori.
We got this.
Got this.
We still got this.
I...
It's so fast.
We still...
Somehow, we're still gonna get it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's fine.
Chop.
Shit!
Chop, chop, chop, chop, chop, chop!
We keep chopping!
Torrance!
We keep chopping until we can't chop no more!
Chop, chop, chop, chop.
Shit!
Please.
Okay.
We chop till we drop.
Nice.
That's right.
Broke your legs!
Broke your ankles!
What you gonna do now?
That's right.
Achille heals you.
Oh, your precious fucking leg.
God!
That's right.
I went om-yom-yom and point fit your ankles.
Oh my god!
Did you...
What the fuck?!
Bro, he just ripped off his leg!
What am I gonna fight now?!
What?
Oh my god, he has three eyes!
Wait, what do...
What do I chop now?
What?
Chop your ass?
But... I don't underst... I don't understand!
What?
Is this how it works?
I'm...
I...
Chop?
Smack, smack, smack, smack, smack your ass!
Smack, smack, smack, smack, smack, smack, smack.
Oh, there was a critical?
I can't tell!
I'm just smacking the ass!
Smack, smack, smack, smack, smack.
Smack, smack.
Okay, okay, he's... he's dead.
I don't know where to smack.
I actually don't know where to smack, guys.
I'm just gonna keep smacking here.
This is the only place I know.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's two fire things at me now.
Oh!
It's okay, I can keep hitting his ass, right?
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, please!
Let's go!
Yeah!
That's... that's fucking right!
Let's go!
Smacked his ass till he died.
What a way to go.
I'm gonna get one of those bad cats in these dragons.
Sensen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The power of chopping.
Let's go!
You know what?
Get in here.
I'll give you a little bit to drink, horse.
Let's...
Drink that!
Drink that to celebrate!
Sagen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is there a grace?
Oh, there is a grace.
Let's go.
I'm just better.
Chop, chop, chop.
Chop this ass.
Let's fucking go.
I love how you ignored all the criticals.
Sometimes I just don't know.
Yeah.
So, do we do endurance and then vigor?
Is that good enough?
Endurance and vigor?
Or...
Or do we do strength...
Uh, any dexterity.
Or strength.
Oh, vigor, zen endurance?
How you dodge, like, four attacks.
I'm not even moving from his butt.
But I just kept...
I was, like, so confused.
I was like...
Why...
Am I not gonna get punished for that?
I...
I did not...
I literally was just going...
All I did was like...
Left click, left click, left click, left click.
Like, up his ass and then not got punished.
You know what?
I think that's a good time to end.
Never punish, guys.
Uh...
I think...
I think this is a good time...
Um...
Uh...
A good time...
To call it here, guys.
Uh...
This is the perfect spot to stop.
Yeah.
I think so, too.
Uh...
I won't be doing a...
Super chat reading today.
Because tomorrow's gonna be a really long day.
So...
Uh...
I wanna make sure I have enough time to, you know...
Rest up...
Uh...
For...
For tomorrow's double streams.
Anyway...
Yeah, we beat two story bosses today.
We're almost hitting...
We're almost getting there.
Remembering the gold...
Uh...
The charity gold.
We're almost getting there.
Uh...
But...
I'm gonna call it here, everyone.
I hope you guys, uh...
Had a great time...
Hang out with me today for Elden Ring.
Don't worry.
We have another...
We have more Elden Ring later this week on Saturday.
So...
Yay!
More Elden Ring!
Hey, guys!
Thank you all for coming, guys.
See?
Look at that.
Our relationship is better now.
Like, see?
Look at that.
It's back to normal.
You and me, Dragoons, we are, like, good backseating and streamer.
Good backseating and streamer relationship, guys.
We have... it's very solid, strong.
Nothing can come between us, guys.
Wait, just scold me once and now.
You gotta try a little harder, Spencer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you said for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
It's okay.
You guys forgive me.
All is forgiven.
Bye-bye.